MEETING OF THE BUDGET SUBPHYLUM --
WE HAVEN'T NUMBER OF ITEMS TO
COVER TODAY AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF MEETINGS
TAKING PLACE ALL OVER THE
BUILDING -- IN TERMS OF
COMMITTEE HEARING SO WE'RE GONNA
TRY.
TO OF BEGIN OUR MEETING WITH THE
INFORMATION ITEMS -- WHEN WE GET
A QUORUM WE NEED AT LEAST ONE OF
THE MEMBER THEN WE CAN TAKE UP
THE VOTE ITEMS OF BUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE AT LEAST THREE MEMBERS HERE
HOPEFULLY ONE ABOUT REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS PRESENT?
AND WHAT IT TO BASICALLY TAKE UP
THE THE BOAT ITEMS SO GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE HEARING PORTION
INFORMATION ITEMS ITEMS THAT
WILL BE VOTED ON TODAY BUT WE'LL
BE GETTING INFORMATION.
AND ANSWERING QUITE GETTING
QUESTIONS ANSWERED -- WILL BEGIN
WITH THOSE AND THEN WHEN WE GET
A QUORUM WILL AT AN APPROPRIATE
TIME TRY TO TAKE A BREAK IN THAT
AND THEN GO FROM THE BOAT ITEMS
ONLY THOSE OF ITEMS THAT DON'T
HAVE PRESENTATIONS THAT ON OUR
AGENDA THAT WE HAVE TO VOTE ON
WHAT.
INDIVIDUALLY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGAN WITH THE
ISSUE ONE WHICH IS THE PENAL
CODE REVIEW BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
AND SURE ASK THOSE WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THAT THE PLEASE COME
[inaudible]
FOR ALRIGHT.
HI CLINT CALLUM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE HAS
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED IN SIZE
FROM ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND WORDS IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE TO ONE POINT TWO
MILLION IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR THAN
FIVE THOUSAND SEPARATE CRIMINAL
PROVISIONS SPECIFYING CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR PENALTIES FOR
CONVICTIONS ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS.
AND CREDIT EARNING ONCE
INCARCERATED.
CONSEQUENTLY THE ADMINISTRATION
IS REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT A NEW COMMITTEE THAT
WILL BE ESTABLISHED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION. TO STUDY AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REVISE THIS
COMPLEX STATUTORY STRUCTURE.
THE NEW COMMITTEE WILL HAVE
SEPARATE POWERS FROM THE
COMMISSION TO MAKE POLICIES AND
TAKE ACTIONS INTERVIEW AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR ON
REVISIONS TO THE PENAL CODE.
THE COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN AN
EFFORT TO SIMPLIFY AND
RATIONALIZE CRIMINAL LAW AND
CRIMINAL PROCEDURES.
ESTABLISHED ALTERNATIVES. TO
INCARCERATION THAT AID
REHABILITATION AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
IMPROVE PAROLE AND PROBATION
SYSTEMS AND ADJUST THE LENGTH OF
CENTS TERMS BASED ON CERTAIN
CONSIDERATIONS.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR TWO ATTORNEY POSITIONS IN
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITION AND
ASSOCIATED COSTS WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO ESTABLISH THE COMMITTEE IN
THE PROPOSED ACTIVITIES.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM --
FINANCE IS NOT UP ILLEGAL --
ONCE I AM FINANCES.
VERY CONFUSING OKAY YES ANY
COMMENTS MILLENNIAL.
NO COMING OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS APPEAR.
THE COMMENTS FROM THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE.
OKAY THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE STAKES IS TO THE SECOND ITEM.
WHICH IS THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
FROM THE RECEIVER'S OFFICE
[inaudible]
YES.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN GOOD
MORNING MOUNTAINS SAY THAT
THOUGH [inaudible]
I USED.
IF YOU DIDN'T SAY THAT I THINK
IT BACK.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CLARK KELSO ONE THE
RECEIVER APPOINTED BY THE
FEDERAL COURT IN THE PLOT A
LITIGATION.
I WITH RESPONSIBILITY FOR CDC
OURS MEDICAL PROGRAM -- I'LL
PROVIDE JUST A FEW ADDITIONAL.
DETAILS OF BACKGROUND THAT I
KNOW THE COMMITTEE IS ALREADY
WHERE UP -- OVERALL WE CONTINUE
TO MAKE STEADY PROGRESS IN
FULFILLING OUR MISSION.
OF IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
MEDICAL CARE THAT IS BEING
DELIVERED TO OUR PATIENTS.
AND ON AN INSTITUTION BY
INSTITUTION BASIS.
TRANSFERRING AUTHORITY OVER TO
THE MEDICAL OVER THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM BACK TO THE STATE.
AS OF TODAY TWENTY FOUR OF CDC
OUR THIRTY FIVE INSTITUTION
THAT'S ABOUT 70%.
HAVE EITHER BEEN DELEGATED BACK
TO CDC ARM FOR ITS MANAGEMENT.
OR RECEIVED A FINDING OF
ACCEPTABLE CARE.
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
THE ELEVEN REMAINING
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
DELEGATED BACK TO THE STATE AND
DO NOT HAVE A FINDING OF
ADEQUATE CARE.
ARE NOW MY PRIMARY FOCUS.
I BELIEVE THAT A FEW OF THESE
ELEVEN WELL FAIRLY EASILY BE
FOUND ADEQUATE.
IN THE NEXT ROUND OF REVIEWS BY
THE O. I. G..
AND WILL THEN BE SUITABLE FOR
DELEGATION BACK TO THE STATE.
THAT IS GOING TO LEAVE US WITH A
SMALL BUT STILL SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
FRANKLY.
SOME OF THE MOST DIFFICULT TO
MANAGE INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE.
BOTH FOR MEDICAL I AM FOR MENTAL
HEALTH -- IN FOR CUSTODY FRANKLY --
I CAN ASSURE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THAT WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER -- TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF CARE IN THOSE MOST
DIFFICULT INSTITUTIONS -- BUT I
DON'T WANT TO PAINT TOO ROSY A
PICTURE A GETTING TO THE FINISH
LINE WITH THESE LAST
INSTITUTIONS IS GOING TO BE A
LOT OF HARD WORK.
REQUIRING CLOSE COOPERATION WITH
AND SUPPORT FROM SECRETARY DIAZ
IN HIS CUSTODY RESOURCES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SECRETARY AND
I AND OUR STAFFS WORK VERY WELL
TOGETHER -- IN WE ARE JOINTLY
COMMITTED TO GETTING THIS JOB
DONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT FOR
THE SUB COMMITTEE TWO OF OUR
MOST IMPORTANT RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS.
OUR FIRST.
I AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS OF
SYSTEM.
A MASS OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROJECT BEGUN A SHORT FIVE YEARS
AGO.
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED AT ALL INSTITUTIONS.
OUR PATIENTS BENEFIT FROM THIS
SYSTEM EVERY SINGLE DAY.
OUR MEDICAL RECORDS AND NOW
FINALLY IN SUCH GOOD ORDER.
THAT OUR PROVIDERS IN NURSES CAN
EASILY TRACK EVERY PATIENT'S
MEDICAL HISTORY.
SEE A MONITOR ALL TEST RESULTS
PRESCRIBE MEDICATIONS AND
MONITOR THEIR ADMINISTRATION.
IN AND PUT PROVIDER IN NURSING
NOTES DOCUMENTING THE CARE THAT
IS BEING DELIVERED.
EQUALLY IMPORTANT MEDICAL
LEADERSHIP OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL AND AT
HEADQUARTERS ARE NOW ABLE TO
MONITOR THE DELIVERY OF CARE IN
A REAL TIME.
AND WE HAVE DATA NOW -- THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO US ABOUT THE WAY
CARE IS BEING PROVIDED -- THAT
THAT IS SIMPLY REMARKABLE AND
THE WERE ABLE TO USE TO IMPROVE
OUR QUALITY -- I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
OVER THE LAST DECADE.
A DECADE AND MAYBE TWELVE YEARS
DOZEN YEARS.
HAS ESSENTIALLY GONE FROM HAVING.
ACTUALLY NO INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS SUPPORTING
ITS OPERATIONS.
VERY RUDIMENTARY SYSTEMS ON
CUSTODY SIDE AND NOT ON HEALTH
CARE. TO HAVING SOME OF THE BEST
IT SYSTEMS WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
IT IS NOT THE CASE THAT EVERY
LARGE I. T. PROGRAM IN THE STATE.
OF FLOUNDERS OF CDC ARE ACTUALLY
IS A A PRETTY GOOD EXAMPLE OF A
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITIONED FROM PAPER TO A
DIGITAL DEPARTMENT.
MY SECOND.
INITIATIVE BUT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT -- IS THAT AFTER
SUBSTANTIAL INTERNAL OPERATION
LAST YEAR I JOIN WITH
UNDERSECRETARY DIANA TOSSED.
IN DIRECTING OUR STAFFS TO
DEVELOP A MEDICATION ASSISTED A
TREATMENT PROGRAM. TO ADDRESS
THE SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
PATIENTS WITHIN CDC ARE WHO HAVE
SUBSTANCE AND OR OPIOID USE
DISORDERS.
INITIALLY WE WILL BE FOCUSING ON
THOSE PATIENTS WHO ARE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK FOR OVERDOSE.
AS THE MEMBERS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE NO SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER.
IS A COMPLEX CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITION -- IT INVOLVES
DOPAMINE DYSREGULATION IN THE
BRAIN THAT CONTROLS REWARD AND
MOTIVATION.
IT CAN LEAD TO UNCONTROLLABLE
CRAVINGS CONTINUED SUBSTANCE USE.
AND OTHER ABBERTON BEHAVIORS --
WHICH CONTRIBUTES TO PERMANENT
DISABILITY PREMATURE DEATH.
AND OTHER ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES
FOR AFFLICTED INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
IN RECENT YEARS OPIOID USE
DISORDER IS THE PRIMARY
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASES IN
FATAL AND NONFATAL OVERDOSES
NATIONALLY.
IN CALIFORNIA.
TAMBIéN CDC ARE.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE
PREVALENCE OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AMONG THE CDC OUR
POPULATION IS APPROXIMATELY 80%.
BUT A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INMATES.
AND THAT AT LEAST 26%.
OF PATIENTS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER HAVE AN OPIOID USE
DISORDER.
CURRENTLY THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATION OFFERS BEHAVIOR
THERAPY USED AT ALL CDC OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
THROUGH VARIOUS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS.
ALTHOUGH MOST OF THE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY SERVICES ARE BASED ON
MODELS THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
BE EFFECTIVE WITH SPECIFIC
GROUPS OF PATIENTS IN THE
OUTSIDE COMMUNITY.
THE RELIABILITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE
TREATMENTS WITHIN CDC ARE IS
UNKNOWN.
THE DATA JUST HASN'T BEEN
COLLECTED AND ANALYZED.
ADDITIONALLY THE CURRENT S. U.
D. TREATMENT MODEL USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
IS NOT BASED ON A MEDICAL
CHRONIC CARE MODEL.
INSTEAD THE TREATMENT DURATION
IS ONLY FIVE MONTHS.
AND CURRENT AVAILABLE TREATMENT
CAPACITY IS LESS THAN TWELVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS PER YEAR.
WE WILL BE PROPOSING -- LATER
THE THIS SPRING A MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT PROGRAM.
INVOLVING LONG TERM COMBINATION
THERAPY WITH MEDICATION AND
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS.
THAT ARE BEST DELIVERED IN AN
INTEGRATED HEALTH CARE SETTING.
USING INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAMS
WHO WILL TAKE CARE OF THEIR
PATIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE.
THIS APPROACH WILL PROVIDE A
GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY.
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY IN
THE DELIVERY OF CLINICAL
TREATMENTS.
AND THAT IN TURN WILL ALLOW
BETTER COST CONTROL AND TO
PROMOTE BETTER POSITIVE OUTCOMES
INCLUDING A DECREASE IN A
RELAPSE.
FATAL AND NONFATAL OVERDOSES.
AN ABNORMAL BEHAVIORS WITHIN THE
PRISON SETTING.
WE BELIEVE IT WILL ALSO
CONTRIBUTE TO A REDUCTION IN
RECIDIVIST.
IN OUR MODEL.
OF TREATMENT WOULD CONTINUE
AFTER RELEASE FROM CDC OUR
CUSTODY.
AND THAT WILL REQUIRE
COORDINATION WITH EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THAT COORDINATION HAS
ALREADY BEGUN.
HELLO LAST NOVEMBER WE CONVENE
DAY TREATING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS
SUMMIT.
IN TEN DIS INCLUDED
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
LEGISLATURE OF LA -- FINANCE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
A COUNTY PROBATION COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES --
THE INTENTION OF THE MEETING WAS
THE TO MEET WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS AND PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO OUR
PLAN. TO ENSURE ACCESS TO CARE
FOR PATIENTS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER.
ESPECIALLY DURING THE HIGH RISK
TRANSITION FROM PRISON. TO THE
FREE WORLD.
ADDITIONALLY THE FINAL SO ALL
THE WAY DOWN FIVE BEST PRACTICES
OPPORTUNITIES AND LEVERAGE
POINTS. TO IMPROVE CARE DURING
TRANSITION IT'S I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH MEMBERS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON THE MANY ISSUES THAT I KNOW
WILL BE INVOLVED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
TREATMENT PROGRAM -- I'VE NOT
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT
PERSONALLY WAS SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I'D LIKE TO EXTEND
AN INVITATION TO DO SO AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PRESENTATIONS.
OKAY.
IT'S FROM FINANCE [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS.
PUBLIC COMMENTS YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO ENDING
THE DRUG WAR AND REPLACING IT.
WITH POLICIES BASED ON HEALTH
COMPASSION HUMAN RIGHTS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE RECEIVERS
PROPOSAL PARTICULARLY ASPECTS TO
ENROLL PEOPLE IN METHADONE OR
BUPRENORPHINE WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED AND TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM DURING THE TRANSITION OUT.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO FATAL DRUG
OVERDOSE.
THERE IS AN OVER REPRESENTATION
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
INCARCERATED IN JAILS OR PRISONS
OR JUSTIN DRUG TREATMENT.
AMONG THE DEAD THEY NEED A WARM
HAND OFF TO DRUG TREATMENT WE'RE
THINK THE PROPOSAL IS SOUND
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS ITEM WAS TO BE HELD OVER --
THE RECOMMENDATION OBVIOUSLY
GOVERNOR SUPPOSE INCLUDE THREE
POINT SIX NINE MILLION. FOR THE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION PHASE TO
THE MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION
PROMISE AND THIRTEEN PRESENTS TO
ENCOURAGING THAT YOU'RE TELLING
US THAT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO
REDUCE OUR IT WILL BASICALLY BE
ABLE TO TAKE OVER ALL OF THEM
BUT TWO IS THAT CORRECT IS THAT
WHAT YOUR NUMBERS ARE SAYING.
THE BILL WE HAVE TWO LEFT THAT'S
REALLY HARD -- IN TERMS OF
DELEGATION BUT IT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE MORE THAN TWO BUT WE
MORE THAN TWO IN LESS THAN SIX
OKAY.
THE WEATHER NUMBER SEEMED SMALL
AND I WAS GETTING A SMALL FOR MY
PERSPECTIVE A LOT BETTER THAN
THIRTY FIVE WHAT EXACTLY --
EXACTLY OKAY FINE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UNFORTUNATELY LEFT LOS OUR
CORPSMAN MR.
STONE UP THE ROOM.
I KNOW CRAFT I WAS TO TELL ME.
STILL THERE SO IT YEAH HE'S
COMING BACK BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO COMMITTEE TO VOTER.
TRACKING DOWN PLEASE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- WHERE THE THIRD ITEM?
WHICH IS A DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND I THINK THAT
PROBABLY WILL BE A LONG.
ONE SO I WANTED.
TO WANT TO GO TO THE NEXT ITEM
WHICH IS -- THIS IS NOT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE MANAGER DEAL POST IS A
HUNTER SAID WORK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WERE WE GOING TO DISCUSS THE
CONTRACT MEDICAL AUGMENTATION --
AS WELL OR YES WE CAN OKAY.
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD THEN -- I AM
DOING READER I AM THE DIRECTOR
OVER FISCAL SERVICES FOR SHE SHE
SHE S. AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
JUST WHAT WOULD LIKE YOU TO
RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS.
THE THE LA -- PRESENTED.
YES.
YES DO YOU WANT TO PRESENT YOUR
QUESTION TO ONE OF THE AUDIENCE.
THANK YOU.
LUCAS MORROW THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- REVIEWING
THIS PROPOSAL WE IDENTIFIED A
FEW QUESTIONS WHICH MADE IT
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE THE LEVEL
FUNDING NECESSARY IN -- TWENTY
NINETEEN NAMELY IT'S UNCLEAR
WHAT THE VACANCIES ARE IN THREE
D. C. R. I. AND HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM FOR HOME VISITORS
ESPECIALLY AROUND THE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS -- AND THE
PROPOSAL THEY SAY THAT THAT I'VE
STOPPED THIRTY POINT THREE
POSITIONS OVER THE AUTHORIZED
AMOUNT.
OF ON THE SAME PROPOSAL AS A
FOOTNOTE SAYING THAT THE 10%
COMMISSION BUT THEY CAN SEE.
AND A SEPARATE PROPOSAL IN
JANUARY THEY MENTION AND 18%
VACANCY RATE FOR THE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS.
SO IT'S UNCLEAR IF THAT'S
POTENTIAL SALARY SAVINGS THAT
CAN BE APPLIED TOWARDS THIS IN
THE UPCOMING BUDGET YOUR IN
ADDITION IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY DOES
NOT INCREASE AND THE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE THAT WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED -- LARGE AMOUNT OF
THE INCREASE COSTS OF RELATED TO
INPATIENT -- KELLER.
AND THAT WOULD BE ATTENTION TO
BE ELIGIBLE.
FOR MEDICAID COVERAGE OKAY THANK.
I'M INTERNET YES THE ON STAFF.
AND MEDICARE -- THIS IS A VERY
MUCH DOWN IN THE WEEDS HOW DO
YOU COUNT VARIOUS NUMBERS -- WE
GOT INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LITTLE
LATE IN THE PROCESS I AND I
THINK -- LET'S FROM ANALYST'S
OFFICE DID NOT HAVE SOME OF OUR
MOST RECENT INFORMATION THAT
MORE CLEARLY EXPLAINS THE ISSUES
THAT LA -- HAS IDENTIFIED -- I
BELIEVE WE HAVE NOW SUPPLY THAT
INFORMATION TO FINANCE AND THEY
HAVE SUPPLY AND NEW INFORMATION
THE LA -- HAVE THAT YET.
OKAY THEY HAVE I WOULD SUGGEST
DUBBED BEFORE WE TAKE THE
COMMITTEE'S TIME UNLESS YOU
REALLY WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF THESE NUMBERS -- THE
PERHAPS WE LET STAFF.
I HAVE ANOTHER CONVERSATION
WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN RESOLVE THE
APPARENT DISCREPANCIES I'M NOT
DENYING THERE WERE DISCREPANCIES
THAT.
YOU WOULD RALLY -- WAS
IDENTIFIED I JUST THINK THAT --
IT IT REALLY IS A STAFF
DISCUSSION THAT WE CAN RESULT
YOU JUST GOT RESCUED BUT THAT'S
OKAY.
OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO WE
DISCUSSION.
JUST A QUICK QUESTION YOU DID
GET THE OF NEW INFORMATION WE WE
RECEIVED INFORMATION ON THAT
HALF IN LEVEL THERE IS A
COMPONENT OF THE FUNDING THAT
DIDN'T MATCH UP WITH THE AMOUNT
OF THE BUDGET -- WE DID RECEIVE
INFORMATION ON WHAT THOSE
ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR AND THAT
HAS BEEN CLARIFIED BUT I STILL
QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF THAT
VACANCY RATES FOR THE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS AND WHY FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS AREN'T BEING
INCREASED.
OKAY SO YOU UNDERSTAND OKAY YES
WITH THE VACANCY RATES -- BUT WE
DID THE PROPOSAL FOR THE BCP FOR
THE APP WOULDN'T INCLUDE THE
TELEMEDICINE PCP POSITIONS AND
THAT INCREASED INFLATED OUR
VACANCY RATE -- BECAUSE WE
HADN'T INCLUDED THOSE -- WHEN WE
DID THE CURRENT PROPOSAL WE
DIDN'T INCLUDE THE THE
TELEMEDICINE WHICH BROADER
VACANCY RATE DOWN WHICH IS
CURRENTLY AT FOUR POINT 6% -- SO
VERY MINIMAL -- IN VERY MINIMAL
SAVINGS THERE -- AS FAR AS THE
REIMBURSEMENT -- WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING AT WAYS TO GET MORE
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE FEDS --
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S OF IT'S A
LENGTHY PROCESS TO GET THAT
REIMBURSEMENT IT TAKES SOMETIMES
UP TO TWO YEARS.
AND SO WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
INCREASES IN OUR REIMBURSEMENT
TO TO DRIVE US TO GO AND ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL REIMBURSEMENT -- AS
WE GET CAUGHT UP IN WE SEE THOSE
INCREASES WILL COME BACK AND AN
INCREASE THAT IF POSSIBLE -- BUT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
OPTICS.
NOT EVERY IN MAY QUALIFIES FOR
MEDI CAL -- WHICH IS ONE ISSUE
WE ONLY GET REIMBURSED FOR
CERTAIN SERVICES AND THEY'RE
SLOWLY -- REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
REIMBURSEMENT RATE THEY STARTED
A 100% AND I BELIEVE IT'S DOWN
CLOSER TO ABOUT 93%.
AND NEXT YEAR WILL BE GOING 290%
SO THOSE FACTORS HAVE MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO TO COME
FORWARD AND MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT
TO THE REIMBURSEMENT AT THIS
TIME OKAY.
OKAY.
I WILL CONTINUE TO HEAR THE WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE WILL
COMMITTEES.
RIGHT FINE ARE WE GOING TO CALL
ROLE AT THIS TIME.
SO THAT WE CAN GO BACK TO THE
BOAT ONLY ITEMS TOP OF THE
AGENDA.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF VOTE
ONLY ITEMS THESE ITEMS --
REQUIRE CONVERT DISCUSSIONS I
SOME EVERYONE'S HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THEM --
UNDERNEATH ITEM EIGHTY NINE
FORTY THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A VOTE ONLY
ITEMS ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES
FOR RESPONSE ACTIVITIES -- SOME
OF IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
ROLL CALL WEBER HI JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
YEAH THAT'S OUT OF THREE OH VOTE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER --
TWO WELL MY COMPUTER'S DECIDED
TO DO ITS OWN THING -- HERE WE
GO -- THAT'S THE SO S. F. L. LOS
ALAMEDA STARBASE CAM CLUB.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALSO ON A THREE OH BOTH
WILL HOLD IT OPEN -- THAT IS THE
ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS THE
US OF THE LOS ALAMEDA WAS
NATIONAL GUARD READY HASN'T BEEN
MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I'M JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
HEY THAT'S OUT OF THE THREE ALSO
WILL HOLD IT OPEN I DIDN'T THE
VOTE ONLY ITEM ISSUE FOR STATE
ACTIVITY DUTY COMPENSATION
ADJUSTMENT.
THIS MOVE IN SECOND ROLL CALL
HOWEVER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT ONLY THREE OH VOTE THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER -- FIVE
THE WORK FOR WARRIORS REMOVED
SPEND MOVED AND SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A THREE OH VOTE THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM ISSUE NUMBER
SIX SACRAMENTO FIRE APPARATUS
MAINTENANCE SHOP IN GENERAL
PURPOSE WAREHOUSE SO WE MOVED IN
SECOND ROLL CALL.
WEBER -- AND ONE WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT THIS IS APPROVED AS A
BUDGET FOR TWENTY NINETEEN WITH
THE REDUCTION COMMENSURATE WITH
THE FACILITY LEASING COSTS IN.
202-022-2020 ONE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT'S THE
MOTION OKAY SO -- LOCAL WEBER I
JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ
STONE.
IT'S OUT OF THREE OH VOTE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS THE
FEDERAL TRUST FUND ALL THREE OF
THIRTY INCREASE.
ROGUE SO MOVED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S ALSO ITEM THREE ALSO WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BRINGS ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH
IS ADJUSTMENT TO PARTNERSHIP
WITH CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS AND
OTHER TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS.
WILL MOVE IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
WITHOUT ONLY THREE OH VOTE IN
AND WE HELD OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS IS ISSUE NUMBER NINE
WHICH IS AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT ACCESSIBILITY.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT OF THE THREE VOTED IN
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ISSUE NUMBER TEN WHICH IS A
STATE WIDE TELEHEALTH SERVICES.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A THREE OH VOTE
IT'LL BE HELD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THE BRINGS IS THE ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM STAFFING.
SO WHAT'S MODE AND SECOND ROLL
CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
STE THREE OH VOTERS OUT ON THREE
OH TO BE HELD OPEN -- THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE WHICH IS A
TOOL OF VISTAPRINT PAROLE
OFFICER RELOCATIONS.
SO I MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S OUT ON A THREE OH VOTE
AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AT THINGS IS THE
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH IS
LOS AND SCROLL OFFICE.
RELOCATION.
SWIM MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ STONE.
IF THAT'S OUT ON A THREE OH VOTE
WE HELD OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ISSUE FOURTEEN WAS THE PART OF
THE GENERAL SERVICES STATEWIDE
SURCHARGE BE INCREASE.
REMOTE IS REMOVED AND SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE THE SON OF THREE
OH BOTH KAY AND WILL HOLD IT
OPEN AND ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN
WHICH IS RENT INCREASES. SEVEN
MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT ON A THREE OH
VOTE ALL THE ITEMS I DON'T THREE
OH VOTES WILL HOLD THOSE ITEMS
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT BRINGS US TO OUR NEXT ISSUE
WHICH IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE.
ISSUE NUMBER
.
THREE OKAY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ANALYSTS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTION
REVITALIZATION -- WE HAVE THE
CENTER FOR JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
WE ALSO HAVE THE HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH HERE -- MILPA AND THEN
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AN ILLEGAL
OKAY [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
YES.
HI MY NAME IS CHUCK SUPPLE AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE DR ROBERT
COMMITMENT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
I'M ALSO JOINED BY DR MARK MARK
GALLI WHO IS THE CIRCUIT
SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES IS TRYING TO
SIR TODAY.
THE DEAD PEOPLE.
AND I WANTED TO PROVIDE AND WE
DON'T HAVE TOO MUCH TIME TO
PRESENT BUT I WANTED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE THE VISION IN
THE MISSION IN THE STRATEGY
WHICH MOVING -- DJJ INTO A NEW
DEPARTMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
AGENCY -- INTO A DEPARTMENT OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
ONE SECOND.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAND AND WAIT
WILL CALL FOR YOU GUYS TO MAKE
THEY WERE STANDING AND I WANT TO
HAVE TO STAND THAT LONG WE WILL
CALL FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENTS NO
PROBLEM.
UHHUH OKAY CONTINUE.
BUT BY MOVING DJJ INTO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
IT'S A CRITICAL INTO IT A NEW
DEPARTMENT.
COMMITTEE THE DEPARTMENT OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
IS A CRITICAL STEP.
ON THE JOURNEY OF STRENGTHENING
DJJ IS ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
FULFILL OUR VISION.
AND MISSION UTILIZING SOME SOME
KEY STRATEGIES AND THE JOURNEY
THAT DJJ HAS BEEN ON CRITICALLY
POST FERAL.
AND THE WORK THAT WE HAVE TO DO
MOVING FORWARD I I SEE IN SORT
OF THREE THREE DIRECTIONS THAT
WE NEED -- TO ADVANCE ONE IS WE
NEED TO SUSTAIN AND ADVANCE THE
GAINS.
THAT WE'VE MADE IN THE FEDERAL
LAWSUIT.
AND FERAL WAS WAS HALF THE
JOURNEY AND THERE IS STILL A
JOURNEY TO CONTINUE AND A DIFF
ADDITIONAL STEPS THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE. TWO WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
CULTIVATE A CULTURE THAT
SUPPORTS THE MISSION AND IT'S A
CULTURE OF SUCCESS.
AND THREE WEEKS NEED TO WHAT I
CALL BUILD UP THE STRENGTH BASS
BASS.
AND I'M GOING TO DESCRIBE.
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
VISION AND MISSION A STRATEGY
LANGUAGE THAT I THINK CAN BEST
BE ADVANCE THROUGH THIS MOVE.
INTO AN OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION.
AN OVERALL VISION.
WHY IS WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE?
KNOW WHAT WE HOPE TO SEE FOR
YOUTH HER ONCE UNDER THE CARE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
IS THAT THEY HAVE TRANSITIONED
SUCCESSFULLY INTO ADULTHOOD.
AND THAT THEY HAVE THE SYSTEM
FROM CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
AND THAT THEY ARE THRIVING AND
ENGAGED MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
THAT THEY'RE ACTIVE ELEMENTS IN
THE RESTORATION OF THE COMMUNITY
ALONG WITH.
THEIR OWN RESTORATION.
AND WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION BEING ABLE
TO FULFILL THIS VISION.
A ROLL A SIMPLE.
THAT WE HELP YOU.
WHO HAVE HURT PEOPLE?
AND HAVE BEEN HURT THEMSELVES.
RETURN SAFELY TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND BECOME RESPONSIBLE AND
SUCCESSFUL.
ADULTS.
IN A FIVE STRATEGIES THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE TRAIL THE
LANGUAGE THAT ARE THE STRATEGIES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
WILL SEEK TO ADVANCE. ONE IS
BUILDING SAFE AND CARING
COMMUNITIES WITHIN [inaudible]
THE DEPARTMENT.
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE GAVE
ENGAGE ALL OF OUR MEMBERS.
AND THAT INCLUDES STAFF YOUTH
FAMILIES.
VOLUNTEERS.
IN FULFILLING THE MISSION.
AND THIS IS KIND OF BORROWED
FROM NORWAY IS BORROWED FROM
GERMAN GERMANY THE NORMALCY
PRINCIPLE THAT FOR THE BEST WAY
TO HELP SOMEONE WHO IS NOT SAFE
TO BE IN THE COMMUNITY LEARN HOW
TO LIVE SAFELY WITHIN A
COMMITTEE AS YOU BUILD NORMAL
SOCIETY WTHIN.
YOUR FACILITY FOR DJJ.
THAT IS -- SKINNY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY YOU
THINK COMMITTEE RESTORATION
THAT'S BUILDINGS SAFE CARING
COMMUNITY WITHIN OUR FACILITIES
THE BEST ENVIRONMENT FOR A YOUNG
PERSON TO LEARN HOW TO BE BLE.
TO THRIVE WITHIN A COMMUNITY AND
IT IS NOT JUST THE STAFF
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FOR FILLING
THAT MISSION.
OF THE YOUTH THEIR FAMILIES OF
VOLUNTEERS AND VISITORS AS WELL
AND HAVE A NEW A NEW EDICT THAT
ANYBODY WHO COMES TO VISIT THE
GOT CONSERVE HIT THE DEPARTMENT --
AT HOUSE TO TO CONTRIBUTE HAS TO
BE ABLE TO BE A PART OF THE
REHABILITATION AND SHARE
SOMETHING OF THEIR EXPERIENCE
SOMETHING TO BE ABLE TO HELP US.
HELP THOSE YOUTH RETURN SAFELY
TO COMMUNITY BECOME RESPONSIBLE
SUCCESSFUL ADULTS THE SECOND
STRATEGY IS DEVELOP A FULLY
PREPARED AND CONTINUALLY
SUPPORTED.
STAFF THAT IS HEALTHY EDUCATED
AND TRAINED TO FULFILL THEIR
UNIQUE AND VITAL ROLES TO
FULFILL THIS MISSION.
AND PART OF THE TRANSITION INTO
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IT
SPEAKS TO SETTING UP A TRAINING
AND DEVELOPMENT INSTITUTE THAT.
WORKS NOT JUST WITH THE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE COMING IN AT
THE VERY BEGINNING BUT ALL OF
OUR STAFF ALL OF THEM ALL THE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO PLAY THEIR UNIQUE ROLES
IN FOR FILLING THAT MISSION.
AND THAT INCLUDES TRAINING
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES AS WELL AS
FOR VOLUNTEERS AS WELL AS FOR
THE YOUTH THEMSELVES TO PLAY A
ROLE IS PEER MENTORS AND THE
LIKE IN HELPING US TO BE ABLE TO
FULFILL THE MISSION.
THE THIRD IS.
TO OFFER TREATMENT TO HELP YOU
HEAL FROM THEIR PAST EXPERIENCES
AND CHANGE THE THINKING BELIEVES
THAT LEAD TO HURTING THEMSELVES
AND OTHERS AND THAT'S VERY MUCH
BUILDING UPON.
THE MYRIAD OF EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAM THAT CAME IN WITH THE
FEDERAL LAWSUIT AND TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICULARLY WITH -- THE THE
MOVE TO A HHS TO BE ABLE TO
CONCENTRATE ALL THE MORE ON
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE AS WELL
LAWS AS THE YOUTH WHO'VE BEEN
AFFECTED BY ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES.
AND THE NEXT WAS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOU TO UNDERSTAND AND RESTORE
THE HARMS CAUSED BY THEIR
ACTIONS RESTORATIVE JUSTICE TO
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE HARMS THAT THEIR ACTION
THAT BROUGHT THEM TO D. J. J. AS
WELL AS THE THE BEHAVIOR THAT
CONTINUES WITHIN DJJ. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THOSE HARMS AND TO
SET UP RESTORED ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY'RE LEARNING HOW TO
REPAIR THOSE HARM TO THE CAN
CONTINUE TO PLAY.
THAT TYPE OF RESTORATIVE ROLE
WHEN THEY RETURNED TO THE
COMMUNITY.
THE NEXUS PROVIDE EDUCATION
TRAINING AND LIFE EXPERIENCES
FOR YOU TO IMAGINE A SPIRE AND
BUILD A PATHWAY TO A SUCCESSFUL
LIFE AND THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
WHAT I CALL THE STRENGTH BASED
SPACE WHERE YOU'RE ABLE TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE.
TO IMAGINE AND BEGIN LIVING A
LIFE WITHIN DJJ THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
WHEN THEY GET OUT.
AND THAT'S A HUGE SECOND PART WE
CAN WE CAN DO ALL WE CAN TO TRY
TO REDUCE REST IN THE WORD.
HELP YOUTH LEARN HOW NOT TO
FIGHT BUT MUCH IN TERMS OF
EFFECTIVE LEARNING THAT WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO BRING INTO DJ JACK.
IS THE REAL POSSIBILITY THAT
THEY HAVE A REASON NOT TO FIGHT
A LIFE THAT THEY CAN LIVE WHEN
THEY GET OUT A NEW IDENTITY THAT
THEY CAN PURSUE.
CREDIBLE MESSENGER MENTORING IS
A BIG PART OF THOSE WHO BETTER
THAN TO BRING INTO OUR
FACILITIES INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO WHAT WE ARE
ASKING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TO DO.
AND HAVE IT BE BELIEVED AND
SUPPORTED IN WAYS IN WHICH THEY
CAN HELP GUIDE THEM TO THIS NEW
IDENTITY AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE OUR CODING
PROGRAM AND OTHERS TO BEGIN.
LIVING THIS LIFE THAT THEY WANT
TO WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
LIVE UPON THEIR RETURN TO THE
COMMUNITY FINALLY.
WE WANT TO BRING PEOPLE WITH
RESOURCES RELATIONSHIPS
EXPERTISE AND PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE INTO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION TO INSPIRE
AND MOTIVATE YOU AND TO BUILD A
CARING COMMUNITY THAT PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT. FOR
THEIR RE ENTRY AND ULTIMATELY
THEY'RE HONORABLE DISCHARGE WE
WANT TO PARTNER WITH PROBATION
WE WANT TO PARTNER WITH.
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS BRINGING THEM
IN FAR EARLIER WE'VE ALREADY
BEEN ABLE TO DO SOME OF THIS SO
THAT THEY'RE GETTING THE MEETING
THE INDIVIDUALS.
IN THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
SUPPORT THERE BEING CONNECTED
WITH ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATING IN
PROGRAMMING IN DC CC.
SO THAT CARING COMMUNITY TRICK
TRANSCENDS DIRECTLY INTO THE
COMMUNITY WE'RE GONNA DO OUR
PART TO BE ABLE TO TRANSFORM.
DJJ THE COMMUNITY OF YOU FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION AND A
STRONG COMMUNITY.
WITHIN OUR FACILITIES BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO BUILD STRONG
COMMUNITIES BACK IN WHERE THE
YOUTH ARE GOING TO BE RETURNING
FOR THAT TRANSITION TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER AT
THIS POINT TO DR GALLEY TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
BENEFITS OF HOW WE'D BE ABLE TO
BETTER ACHIEVE THISWITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
THANK YOU CHUCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE -- I
MARK KELLY I'M THE SECRETARY FOR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES -- AND
AS I THINK ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
IN FRONT OF US I THINK IT'S IT'S
TO INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITIES. ONE
TO SUPPORT THE YOUTH IN IN THE
IN OUR CUSTODY WITH THE BASS
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN IMAGINE
ONES WE WOULD WANT. FOR
OURSELVES AND OUR OWN CHILDREN
IN OUR OWN FAMILY MEMBERS AND BE
ABLE TO BRING THOSE THOSE TO
BEAR IN A VERY MEANINGFUL WAY.
AT A THE PRIVILEGE TO VISIT WITH
CHALK A COUPLE WEEKS AGO THE
MENTOR FACILITY SAW THE COATING
PROGRAM WHICH IS FANTASTIC AND
AND BELIEVE SO MUCH MORE.
LIKE THAT CAN HAPPEN THROUGH OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR OUR NEW
DEPARTMENT AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AS YOU KNOW THE TWELVE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES MANY OF THEM.
PROVIDE THE SUBSTRATE IN THE
SERVICES FOR SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
THAT -- WHAT A TREMENDOUS CHANCE
TO BRING SOME OF THAT EFFORT AND
ENERGY -- TOGETHER WITH THE
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT --
SECRETARY D. AS HAS ALREADY
BUILT -- ADD A JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND TO SCALE THINGS AND A VERY
MEANINGFUL WAY. TO ALLOW US TO
BRING -- EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT WE KNOW FROM OUR
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORLDS TO THOSE SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE OUR
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS TO COME
IN.
AND TO REALLY BUILD COMMUNITY
EARLY WITH WITH ARE YOU. TO
ENSURE THAT THE HEALTH CARE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING IS OF THE
HIGHEST QUALITY AND THAT YOU TO
HAVE HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE
TRANSITION SAFELY TO COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS WHO CAN CONTINUE THAT
CARE.
AND PROVIDE THE SUPPORT TO THE
FAMILIES -- WHETHER IT'S IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE OUR
PHYSICAL HEALTH.
ARENAS ADDITIONALLY I THINK
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY REINVENT HOW WE DO
TRANSITIONS -- OUR YOUTH TO
RETURN TO THEIR COMMUNITIES THEY
GO BACK AND THE MORE WE ALLOW
THE SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE IN OUR
COUNTIES IN OTHER CITIES. TO TO
REALLY BE CALM RECEIVING CENTERS
FOR THOSE YOUTH WITH A WITH A
REALLY STRONG PLAN FOR ACTION
THAT FOCUSES ON THAT COMMUNITY
REINTEGRATION AND RESTORATION --
THERE'S A REAL CHANCE TO DO THIS
IN AN INCREDIBLE WAY TO NOT ONLY
CATCH UP WITH OTHER PLACES ARE
ARE ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT TO
REALLY BECOME A LEADER IN THIS
AREA -- I WAS I WAS IMPRESSED BY --
THE YOUTH SAID I HAD A CHANCE TO
MEET AND TALK WITH AND THE
INTEREST THAT MANY HAD IN --
FIGURING OUT WHICH OPPORTUNITIES
WERE AVAILABLE AND I THINK WE
HAVE THE THE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
WE HAVE A GREAT CHANCE TO
PARTNER WITH CHALK IN THE TEAM
TO REALLY -- BRING THIS OVER IN
A VERY SUCCESSFUL AND SEAMLESS
WAY AND SUPPORT THE STAFF TO
BUILD ON SUCCESS IS THAT THEY
ALREADY HAVE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO TO MAKING THAT
HAPPEN AND SUPPORTING -- THIS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY.
MOVE CALIFORNIA FORWARD IN A
BOLD AN INCREDIBLE.
THANK YOU OF GREAT GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M MORE IN WASHBURN WITH THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
SINCE OUR FOUNDING IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE CJ CJ HAS WORKED
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE BOUND FOR THE
STATE YOUTH CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM.
AND WE'VE CLOSELY MONITORED
CONDITIONS IN THE FACILITIES
IN FEBRUARY WE RELEASED A REPORT
WHICH I BELIEVE YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU.
DETAILING HOW EVERYDAY LIFE HAS
CHANGED FOR YOU SINCE THE STATE
WAS RELEASED.
FROM A YEARS LONG CONDITIONS
LAWSUIT CALLED THE FERAL LAWSUIT.
FERRELL BEGAN IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS IN RESPONSE TO
HORRIFIC ABUSES IN THE
INSTITUTIONS AND IT LASTED FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE.
HOWEVER SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
DJJ FACILITIES HAVE SEEN AN
ABRUPT END. TO THE REPORTING
INSPECTIONS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIRED UNDER FERAL
[inaudible]
NOW NO SINGLE OVERSIGHT BODY
EXISTS TO ENSURE THE DJJ IS
FULFILLING ITS BASIC OBLIGATION.
TO KEEP YOU SAFE.
AND TO PREPARE THEM TO RETURN
HOME.
OUR RESEARCH EVALUATED ALL
ASPECTS OF LIFE AT DJJ.
FROM INTAKE TO RE ENTRY.
AND A FEW KEY THEMES EMERGED.
ONE BUT THE DJJ INSTITUTIONS
REMAIN DOMINATED BY A CULTURE OF
VIOLENCE AND FEAR. TWO THAT
YOUTH ARE ROUTINELY ISOLATED.
BOTH FROM HEALTHY SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS AND FROM THEIR
FAMILIES BACK ON AND THREE THE
DJJ IS INHERENTLY NON
REHABILITATIVE. FOR YOUTH IN DJJ
VIOLENCE IS A PART OF THEIR
DAILY LIVES.
ON AVERAGE THIRTY THREE YOUTH
PER HUNDRED IN THE FACILITIES
ARE INVOLVED IN FIGHTS BEATINGS
OR RIGHTS EACH MONTH.
AND THERE'S ALSO BEEN A DRAMATIC
SPIKE IN USE OF FORCE BY STAFF.
WITH THE RATE THAT'S INCREASED
NEARLY THREE FOLD SINCE THE END
OF FERAL [inaudible]
DJJ.
FRANKLY IS DOMINATED BY CULTURE
OF FEAR THE PLACE IS YOUTH ON
HIGH ALERT AND EXACTS.
A SIGNIFICANT PSYCHOLOGICAL TOLL.
AND STAFF OFTEN RESPOND TO THIS
VIOLENCE BY ISOLATING YOUTH.
AND DEPRIVING THEM OF HEALTHY
SOCIAL INTERACTIONS.
IN THE MOST EXTREME EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS THE BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM BTP.
WHICH PLACES YOUTH IN RELATIVE
ISOLATION FOR WEEKS MONTHS AND
SOMETIMES EVEN YEARS ON AND
PROFOUNDLY AFFECTING THEIR
HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
AND BECAUSE DJJ IS REMOTELY
LOCATED.
MANY YOUTH ARE ALSO ISOLATED
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES BACK CALL.
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF YOU THE
DJJ ARE PLACED MORE THAN A
HUNDRED MILES FROM THEIR HOME
COUNTIES WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM. TO MAINTAIN
A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH LOVED
ONES DURING THIS CRITICAL PERIOD
IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
SO BOTH THE ISOLATION AND
VIOLENCE YOUTH EXPERIENCE AT DJJ
DIRECTLY UNDERMINES ITS
REHABILITATIVE AIMS.
AND THE RESULT IS POOR OUTCOMES.
SO THREE QUARTERS OF YOUTH ARE
RE ARRESTED MORE THAN HALF A RE
CONVICTED AND MORE THAN A THIRD
RETURN TO STATE CUSTODY WITHIN
THREE YEARS OF RELEASE FROM DJJ.
AND OUR SURVEY FOUND THAT
APPROXIMATELY 60% OF YOUTH ARE
NEITHER EMPLOYED NOR ENGAGE IN
AN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM WHEN THEY
RETURN TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
YOUTH LEAVE DJJ WITH DEEP TRAUMA
AND INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
UPON RETURNING HOME MANY USE
TALK ABOUT THE CHALLENGE OF JUST
SLEEPING THROUGH THE NIGHT.
AND HOW IT FELT TO TRY TO SHED
THE HYPER VIGILANCE THAT THEY
NEEDED JUST TO SURVIVE IN THE
FACILITIES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY OUR DECADES OF
RESEARCH HAVE FOUND THAT THESE
CONDITIONS ARE ENDEMIC TO LARGE
CONGER GET REMOTE INSTITUTIONS
LIKE DJJ.
AND NO AMOUNT OF SUPERFICIAL
REFORM OR FACILITY UPGRADES WILL
BRING THE CURRENT INSTITUTIONS.
CLOSER TO USE HOMES AND FAMILIES
OR ENSURE YOU SAFETY.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THESE ISSUES
AND THANK YOU FOR PUTTING YOU
THREATEN CENTER IN TODAY'S
DISCUSSION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ELIZABETH
CALVIN -- SENIOR ADVOCATE IN THE
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS DIVISION OF
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH.
A NON GOVERNMENTAL.
INDEPENDENT ORGANIZATION WORKING
IN SOME NINETY COUNTRIES.
I AM COMMITTED TO ENDING THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AS WE
KNOW IT.
ONCE AND FOR ALL.
AS I THINK YOU PROBABLY KNOW
THOSE ARE THE WORDS OF OUR
GOVERNOR.
GOVERNOR NEWSON WHO JUST DAYS
AFTER HIS INAUGURATION CHOSE TO
VISIT A YOUTH PRISON AS ONE OF
HIS FIRST OFFICIAL ACTS.
STANDING WITH YOUTH HE ANNOUNCED
HIS DECISION TO REMOVE THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
FROM THE STATE'S ADULT.
CORRECTION AGENCY AND SET IN
MOTION CHANGES TO HOW CALIFORNIA
TREATS ITS YOUTH.
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
THIS IS A BOLD ACT.
IT'S A BIG MOVE.
WE UNDERSTAND TO THAT IT IS ALSO
A DIFFICULT TASK.
EXTRICATING A DIVISION FROM A
LARGE AGENCY AND DOING IT IN A
WAY THAT PROTECTS THE INTERESTS
OF STAFF.
YOUTH AND COMMUNITIES WILL
REQUIRE NO DOUBT GRAPPLING WITH
ON GLAMOROUS AND THORNY DETAILS.
WE SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO ACCOMPLISHING THIS
MOVE.
IN A SYSTEMATIC AND THOUGHTFUL
MANNER.
IT'S NOT INSIGNIFICANT THE
GOVERNOR CHOSE TO FOCUS ON THE
NEEDS AND THE POTENTIAL.
OF OUR YOUTH WHO ARE IN THE DEEP
END OF THE SYSTEM.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
IS ABOUT YOUTH WHO MANY WOULD
JUST AS SOON.
GIVE UP ON THE TO THE
RECOGNITION OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT AN UP
LIFT ALL YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT'S A GOOD PLACE TO START.
IF IT STOPS THERE THOUGH WE WILL
ALL LOOK BACK ON THIS MOMENT.
AND WE'LL REALIZE THAT AN
OPPORTUNITY WAS SQUANDERED.
THE PROPOSAL ONLY ADDRESSES THE
STATE SYSTEM WHICH REPRESENTS
LESS THAN 1%.
ACTUALLY POINT 3% OF YOUTH WHO
ARE REFERRED TO THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR SEVENTY THOUSAND YOUTH
WERE REFERRED TO PROBATION AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL.
CALIFORNIA HAS A DEEP BENCH OF
KNOWLEDGEABLE YOUTH JUSTICE
JUSTICE ADVOCATE TO HAVE WORKED
ON THESE ISSUES LITERALLY FOR
DECADES.
OUR NORTH STAR IS A SYSTEM THAT
OFFERS OPPORTUNITIES FOR HEALING
AND TRANSFORMATION FOR SURVIVORS
OF CRIME YOUTH ACCUSED OF CRIMES
ARE FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
THE GOVERNOR'S VISION IS TO END
JOURNAL JUSTICE AS WE KNOW IT.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS REPRESENT
WHAT SHOULD BE IN ITS PLACE.
YOU HAVE OUR MARCH TWENTY
SEVENTH MEMO.
REFLECTING TWO YEARS OF WORK ON
A PLAN FOR REFORM IN CALIFORNIA.
IN IT WE OFFER SEVERAL CONCRETE
SMALL STEPS THAT SHOULD BE TAKEN
IN THIS BUDGET. TO ACHIEVE MORE
HOLISTIC CHANGE.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
THERE'S BEEN A SHIFT OF CONTROL
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
YET PROBLEMS HAVE PERSISTED EACH
TIME.
WHICH HE EACH OF THOSE STRIPS
THOSE MOST AFFECTED BY THE
LINGERING PROBLEMS ARE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WE URGE YOU TO CONSIDER A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE PROCESS FOR THE
MOVE ONE THAT INVOLVES A DIVIDE
A DIVERSE BODY OF STAKEHOLDERS.
AND EXPERTS INCLUDING THOSE WITH
DIRECT EXPERIENCE IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
AND TAKES THE TIME TO THINK
THROUGH HOW TO SET IN MOTION
BROADER CHANGES FOR THE STATE'S
YOUNG PEOPLE -- MEMO LAYS OUT
FIVE BIG IDEAS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR TRANSFORMATION AND
ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL FOR THE MOVE OF DJJ I'M
GOING TO QUICKLY REVIEW TO MR
VIDEO.
NEXT TO ME WILL DESCRIBE --
THREE FIRST WE ASK.
THAT WHILE PLANNING FOR THE DJJ
MOVE THE STATE SHOULD EXPLORE
ESTABLISHING A YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
FRAMEWORK ACROSS ALL YOUTH
SERVING SYSTEMS IN THE STATE.
A CENTRALIZED AUTHORITY SHOULD
BE CREATED EITHER AS A
STANDALONE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY OR UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
AN EXISTING AGENCY WITH
DEDICATED INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RESOURCES TO ENSURE COORDINATION.
EFFICACY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACROSS ALL YOUTH SERVING SYSTEMS
NOT DRESSED THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
WE RECOMMEND BUDGET ALLOCATIONS
TO CREATE A COMMISSIONER TASK
FORCE THAT WOULD GIVE INPUT ON
THE TRANSITION OF DJJ OUT OF CDC
OUR MAP ALL STATES.
A YOUTH SERVING SYSTEMS FUNDING
STREAMS AND SERVICES.
EXAMINE EXISTING OPERATIONS AND
FUNCTIONS AND DETERMINE HOW THEY
CAN BE RECONFIGURED IN ORDER TO
BE GROUNDED IN YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PRINCIPLES.
AND TO GIVE INPUT ON BEST
PRACTICES FOR THE LEADERSHIP AND
STAFF TRAINING RULES OF THIS
AGENCY.
WE ASK THAT THIS COMMAND THIS
COMMISSIONER TASK FORCE GET THE
TIME NEEDED TO PROCEED WITH THE
MOVE AND EXPLORE NEXT STEPS AT
THE SAME TIME.
WE RECOMMEND THAT SUCH A BODY
SUBMIT A PLAN TO THE GOVERNOR BY
MARCH -- TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND
THE NEW AGENCY BE LAUNCHED NO
EARLIER THAN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE YOU CAN
REFER TO PAGES ELEVEN AND TWELVE
FOR MORE DETAILS ON THIS.
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS TO
REMOVE ALL THE SEC AUTHORITY
OVER CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
CALIFORNIA HAS NO CENTRALIZED
AUTHORITY WITH ENFORCEMENT POWER
OVER ITS YOUTH JUSTICE SYSTEMS.
THROUGH REALIGNMENT AND OTHER
FORCES THE STATE'S ROLL OVER
YOUTH HAS DIMINISHED WELL A
BIGGER RATIO OF CASES HAVE BEEN
HANDLED AT THE COURT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
SINCE THE END OF THE FERAL
LITIGATION THERE'S BEEN NO
MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT OVER DJJ.
AND WHILE THE B. S. C. C.
MAINTAINS OVERSIGHT OVER COUNTY
FACILITIES IT IS A WEEK.
AND THERE IS IN FACT AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL OPINION CONCLUDING.
THAT THE FCC REGULATIONS ARE NOT
ENFORCEABLE.
THE STATE DOES NOT PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP FOR ONGOING SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT.
POLICIES AND PRACTICES FOR YOUTH
UNDER COUNTY SUPERVISION.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE SAME
COMMISSION DEVELOP A PLAN TO
TRANSFER THE BSE SEAT AUTHORITY
OVER YOUTH.
AND CHILDREN TO A NEW AGENCY
EFFECTIVE JANUARY.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE YOU CAN
REFER TO PAGES TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN ARE MEMO FOR DETAILS
REGARDING THIS.
THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR.
OF PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING.
I BELIEVE THAT WE COULD BE OUT.
AN IMPORTANT HISTORICAL TURNING
POINT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN I STARTED
THIS MY NAME IS ISRAEL VIA ON
THE PROGRAMMING PARTY CORNER
WITH ME BY OUT IN SALINAS.
A WE ARE PROUD MEMBERS ALLIANCE
OF BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR WE ARE
PROUD MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LINE FOR YOU THANK COMMUNITY
JUSTICE.
WE BOUGHT IS CULTIVATING CHAIN
MAKERS TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES WE PROVIDE
INNOVATIVE CULTURALLY RELEVANT
APPROACH THAT SUPPORT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
AND WORK TO EN MASS
INCARCERATION.
WE USE HEALING TO FORM
RELATIONSHIPS SENATE APPROACHES
TO INCUBATE NEXT GENERATION
LEADERSHIP AND INFRASTRUCTURE
WHILE STRIVING FOR RACIAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
A SMALL GROUP OF YOUTH JUSTICE
ADVOCATE JOINED TOGETHER IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO DEVELOP A
RESEARCH BASED.
MULTI FACETED APPROACH TO TEN
YEARS OF CHANGE TO CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO ITS YOUTH.
THE END RESULT WAS TEN IDEAS FOR
TEN YEARS THAT CHANGED THE
RESULT WHAT A SEVENTY THE RESULT
WAS A SEVENTY PAGE DOCUMENT.
THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN RELEASED
BUT OUR MEMEL TO SUMMARIZE SOME
OF THE IDEAS WE FOUGHT MOST
RELEVANT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED MOVE.
WE ARE FORMING CARS RATED WHERE
FAMILY OF YOUTH IN THE SYSTEM WE
ARE RESEARCHERS WHERE ADVOCATES
ACTIVISTS ATTORNEY THAT
PROFESSORS.
OUR EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE IS
DIVERSE AND WE'LL THE COMMON
GOAL OF HEALING AND EMPOWERMENT
FOR OUR YOUTH AND COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONAL ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
SIGNED ON IN SUPPORT OF THE
IDEAS IN THE MEMO WE PROVIDED.
YOU IN LATE MARCH AND I BELIEVE
YOU GUYS HAVE AN UPDATED LIST.
MRS CALVIN REVIEWED TWO OF THE
FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS I WHEN I
DESCRIBED THREE ADDITIONAL ONES
FIRST IN THE CONTEXT OF PLANNING
FOR THE DJJ MOVE THE STATE
SHOULD EXPLORE ENDING THE USE OF
LARGE.
PRISON LIKE FACILITIES FOR CASES
AB JUDICATA IN JUVENILE COURT.
YOUTH CURRENTLY HOUSED AT THE
DAY AFTER JUVENILE COURT
ADJUDICATION SHOULD BE MOVED TO
SMALL STATE RUN.
REGIONAL REGIONALLY BASED
FACILITIES ARE CLOSER TO HOME.
OUR AT OUR MEMEL OUTLINED SOME
OF THE PARAMETERS NO NEW
BUILDINGS.
USING EXISTING UNDER UTILIZED OR
CLOSE COUNTY BUILDINGS AND
LEAVING INCARCERATION AS A LAST
RESORT.
BY FURTHER LIMITING YOUTH
ELIGIBLE FOR CORPORATION. FOR
THE BUDGET WE RECOMMEND THE
COMMISSION SLASH TASK FORCE TO
EXPLORE HOW THIS WOULD WORK AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
LOCATION AND NUMBER OF
REGIONALLY BASED FACILITIES BY
MARCH.
TWENTY TWENTY SECOND THE STATE
SHOULD INVEST FURTHER IN
COMMUNITY BASED INTERVENTIONS
AND ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION.
CALIFORNIA TO STOP RELYING ON
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO RESPOND TO
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AND THE STAFF INVEST IN YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT.
IF THEY CAN DO THIS BY RE
DIRECTING EXISTING FUNDING
STREAMS AND CREATING NEW ONCE
DESCRIBED ON PAGE.
SIX THE BUDGET STEPS WOULD
INCLUDE SENDING BENCHMARKS FOR
RESEARCHING COMMUNITY
ALTERNATIVES.
POWER TIGHTENING COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION.
FINALLY WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
STATE START THE PROCESS OF RE
DRAFTING ITS YOUTH JUSTICE COLD.
IT HAS BEEN NEARLY SIXTY YEARS
SINCE CALIFORNIA LAST OVER ALL
THE COLD. TO PUT THIS IN CONTEXT
THE LAWS THAT GOVERN WHAT
HAPPENED TERM WAS ONE WHAT
CHILDREN WERE FIRST WRITTEN
AROUND THE SAME TIME.
THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE BUILDING
WAS ERECTED IF THEY HAD THE TERM
AT THE BILL IN THIS OLD AND
OUTDATED IT NO LONGER SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
NEEDS TO BE LEVELED.
AND BUILT A NEW.
THE SAME IS TRUE FOR YOUTH
JUSTICE LAWS THE LAWS ARE
WRITTEN WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF
DECADES OF RESEARCH ON EFFECTIVE
RESPONSES TO YOUTHFUL MISS
BEHAVIOR.
AND ADOLESCENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AND PRINCIPLES OF POSITIVE YOUTH
JUSTICE.
MOREOVER THE LAWS WERE WRITTEN
WITHOUT KNOWLEDGE OF STRUCTURAL
AND SYSTEMATIC BIAS.
THAT HAVE HAD A SIGNIFICANT AND
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON YOUTH
OF COLOR.
OUR RECOMMENDATION IS THAT.
AS A FIRST STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION A NEW PURPOSE CLAUSE
BE ENACTED FOR THE WEEK COLD.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE PURPOSE
CLASS PROPOSED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET TRAILER
BILL IS FOR THE NEW DEPARTMENT
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION.
I WHILE WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSED
CHANGE IT IS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT IT WILL APPLY.
ONLY TO STATE FACILITIES AS A
LITTLE BIT AS ELIZABETH
DESCRIBED THIS IS LESS THAN 1%
OF YOUTH WHO TOUCH OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
WE PROPOSES START WITH THE NEW
PURPOSE STATEMENT FOR THE WHOLE
STATE WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
PROPOSED PURPOSE BECAUSE THIS IS
GREATER ACKNOWLEDGEMENT.
THAT HARMS OF JUSTICE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT FALL MOST HEAVILY ON
YOUTH OF COLOR AND REFORMS.
MUST.
PRIORITIZE ANY RACIAL
DISPARITIES.
BUT THEIR SELF SO MUCH MORE TO
DO MY EXPERIENCE AS A MEMBER OF
THE TARA FIFTEEN WORK GROUP.
THAT WORKED ON TARA FIFTY
REVISIONS MADE CLEAR THAT UNTIL
THE STATE MAKES CONCRETE CHANGES
IN THE SYSTEM OF OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT.
OUR EFFORTS WILL BE USELESS MANY
THOUGHTFUL POWERFUL CHANGES WERE
MADE TO THE TARA FIFTEEN
REGULATIONS BUT THE STATE HAS NO
WAY TO ENFORCE THEM.
I KNOW VERY WELL HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS MY FIRST CONTACT WITH
THE WITH THE LAW WAS IN SIXTH
GRADE FOR AN ALTERCATION.
I CONTINUE TO ESCALATE FROM
THERE I AM NOW FORTY ONE AND
SPENT OVER SEVENTEEN YEARS OF MY
LIFE LOCKED UP IN JUVENILE HALL
GROUP HOMES SEE WHY STATE AND
FEDERAL PRISON.
NOT ONCE WHAT IN THE SYSTEM WAS
MY PROBLEM EVER QUESTION NO WAY
THE ROOT CAUSES OF MY BEHAVIOR
AS A CHILD EVER ADDRESSED
INSTEAD THE SYSTEM BECAME PART
OF MY HISTORY OF TRAUMA.
I NEVER EVEN HEARD THE WORD TROM
OR HAD ANY IDEA WHAT IT MEANT
UNTIL I WAS OUT AND INVOLVED
WITH THE COMMUNITY BASED
CULTURALLY GROUNDED ORGANIZATION
THAT'S RUNNING ME WITH LOVE AND
GAVE ME THE TOOLS TO HEAL MYSELF.
AND NOW ALLOW ME TO HELP OTHERS.
DINNER AFTER THURSDAY'S EVERY
PERSON WAS SACRED EVERY PERSON
WAS EMBRACED EVERYONE HAD A ROLE
TO PLAY.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE RIGHT THERE.
EVERY PERSON EVERY YOU HAS VALUE
IS SACRED AND MUST BE EMBRACED.
I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA CAN EMBRACE
ALL ITS YOUTH.
SOME OF IT HAS BEGAN DJJ HAS
STARTED BRINGING A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. TO THE
YOUTH PRESENCE AND ALLOWING
PEOPLE WHO THE YOUTH WILL RELATE
TO TO BE MENTORS AND GUIDES.
ME BY REGULARLY MEETS WITH YOU
THAT THE JJ AND I KNOW WE'RE
HAVING A TREMENDOUS IMPACT.
WE SPOKE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO MOVIE JJ AWAY FROM
CORRECTIONS AND TO STATE TO SET
IN MOTION THE STEPS RECOMMENDED
HERE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE BY WORKING
TOGETHER WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
WE WILL END YOU THINK CAR
SERRATION AND IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR ALL OF OUR YOUTH I CONTINUE
TO LEAD THE NATION WERE JUVENILE
JUSTICE IS CONCERNED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ERIN EDWARDS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE HAVE RELEASED
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE -- TO
EFFECTUATE THIS PROPOSED
TRANSFER -- LAST LAST WEEK -- WE
KNOW THAT THIS -- ISSUES OF
GREAT INTEREST TO MEMBERS -- WE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AS
WE'VE BEEN DEVELOPING THE
DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL.
AND NOW THAT WE HAVE RELEASE
LANGUAGE WE BEFORE -- TO ROBUST
SUBSTANTIVE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
DETAILS AND WITH FORD ENGAGING
WITH YOU ALL AND YOUR STAFF --
AS WELL AS EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS
IN THIS PROCESS -- AND WE HOPE
TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT MOVING
FORWARD.
OKAY [inaudible]
LL.
LUCAS MORE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND CONSIDERING
THIS PROPOSAL WE IDENTIFIED A
FEW KEY QUESTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS DOES DJ
NEED TO BE REORGANIZED TO
IMPROVEREHABILITATION -- WE
NOTE THAT.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT SPECIFIC
BARRIERS EXIST TO REHABILITATION
WITHIN THE CURRENT STRUCTURE.
AND IN ADDITION IT'S NOT CLEAR
HOW THE COURT SYSTEM IS
PERFORMING THE MOST RECENT DATA
ON RECIDIVISM.
IS FUN THE COHORT WITH WHO IS
RELEASED AND 200-011-2000 --
TWELVE THAT WAS WHILE THE FELLOW
AUSSIE WAS STILL UNDER
LITIGATION.
IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THE COURT
SYSTEM AS A PERFORMING NOW THAT
ADDITIONAL CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE -- AND IN ADDITION WHILE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
IDENTIFIED SUB WILL BENEFIT
STONE THIS CONVERSATION -- IT'S
NOT GO WHAT POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES THIS REORGANIZATION
COULD HAVE -- FOR INSTANCE IT
COULD COMPLICATE THE
COORDINATION OF SO RECESS
BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS -- AND THEN.
WE ALSO -- OF WHAT ALL THE
ALTERNATIVE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
POSSIBLE TO IMPROVE
REHABILITATION IF THAT IS
DESIRED APPROACH TO TAKE -- FOR
INSTANCE WE COULD POTENTIALLY
REALIGNED THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO THE COUNTIES OTHER
THAN HAVING A SEPARATE STATE AND
COUNTY SYSTEM THIS IS.
OUR RECOMMENDATION THAT OUR
OFFICE HAS -- PUT FORWARD IN THE
PAST -- ANOTHER APPROACH WOULD
BE TO CONTINUE THE CURRENT
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURAL BUT
MAKE CHANGES WITHIN IT -- OR
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THIRD PARTY
OVERSIGHT.
AND THEN FINALLY -- WE RAISE THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THEY SHOULD
GO THROUGH TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION --NOTING THAT THE
PREVIOUS REALIZATIONS OF THE
STATE'S JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
HAVE GONE THROUGH THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH REORGANIZATION PROCESS
THAT ESTABLISHMENT STATUTE.
AND IT'S NOT MADE CLEAR WHY THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL SHOULD GO
THROUGH TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION
INSTEAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FOR MEMBERSHIP THE
SYSTEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SECRETARY NICE TO MEET YOU
WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND AND IT'S WITH
STUBBLE LICENSE YOU AGAIN I SEE
THE BOTH OF YOU HERE.
I THINK FOR THIS DISCUSSION.
WE NEED TO RE FRAME.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
MISTER SUPPLE YOU TALKED ABOUT?
KIDS WHO HURT PEOPLE AND TO
THEMSELVES OF BEEN HURT LET'S
REFRAME THAT KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN
HURT.
BECAUSE IF WE'RE IF THIS IS A
STEP [inaudible]
THAT.
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO BE
TAKING AND IS WHAT I SAW THIS
PROPOSED I WAS VERY EXCITED
ABOUT IT.
BUT IF ALL WE DO IS REMOVE DJJ
INTO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AND JUST MOVE THIS INCARCERATION
PEAS AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
I THINK WE'VE MISSED A REAL
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
AND THAT IS TO RE.
HOW WE ADDRESS KIDS AND I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SAY KIDS AT
RISK EVEN THOUGH MY GOOD FRIEND
HERE WILL ALWAYS CHANGE?
KIDS TOOK TOUGH TALK ABOUT KIDS
ARE PROMISE.
I KNOW THAT'S OF THIS CAN BE A
HARD ONE FOR ME TO ALWAYS
REMEMBER.
BECAUSE THESE KIDS ARE KIDS WHO
HAVE STRUGGLED AND SUFFERED
THEIR THEIR ORIGINS THERE.
CHALLENGES ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN
THOSE KIDS TO GET REMOVED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
ULTIMATELY SO IF WE RE THINK THE
SYSTEM THAT'S FOR CHILDREN
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THAT HAVE CHALLENGES AND WHO WE
NEED TO HELP ED WHO DESERVE OUR
HELP.
ESSENTIALLY NO WRONG DOOR FOR
ANY CHILD NOW I THINK WE'RE WE
HAVE SOMETHING.
KIDS WHO BUT OF ALL THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM MAY HAVE.
AND SOME ISSUES THAT AND THAT
NEED TO BE DEALT WITH A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY THAT AT THAT
OTHER KIDS DON'T NEED BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT INVOLVED IN IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT THAT'S THERE
SOMETIMES FINE LINES THERE THAT
THAT.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
BUT ULTIMATELY ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES FOR ALL KIDS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
ULTIMATELY MAKE THE NEED FOR A
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
DOWN THE LIGHT.
HOPEFULLY IDEAL -- THAT'S I
THINK THE SYSTEM WE CAN STRIVE.
FOR SO IF WE THINK ABOUT THIS
AGENCY AS BEING ONE THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO COMBINE A NUMBER OF
THESE COMPONENTS WHERE WE SERVE
KIDS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
WHETHER THEY'RE HOMELESS WHETHER
THEY'RE JUSTICE INVOLVED WHETHER
THEY'RE IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM WAR.
POTENTIALLY IS TO BE REMOVED
FROM HOMES A NUMBER OF COUNTIES
HAVE IMPLEMENTED DIFFERENCE
RESPONSE SYSTEMS WHERE THEY'RE
GIVING SERVICES TO FAMILIES
BEFORE THAT CHILD NEEDS TO BE
REMOVED.
THOSE CASES ARE ALSO DEALING
WITH.
ISSUES IN THOSE FAMILIES THAT
MIGHT PREVENT A CHILD THEN FROM
BEING JUSTICE INVOLVED.
BECAUSE THOSE FAMILIES ARE
GETTING THE HELP THAT THEY NEED.
SO WE CAN BRING WELL HEALTH
COMPONENTS INTO THIS WE CAN
BRING.
HEALTH COMPONENTS INTO THIS.
CULTURAL ISSUES FAMILY ISSUES
ADVERTISE THAT EXPERIENCES INTO
A SYSTEM TO ADDRESS A LOT OF
THOSE THEN WE DON'T NEED.
WHAT HAS DEVELOPED INTO THIS
PUNITIVE SYSTEM AND I KNOW WE'RE
STRUGGLING LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE
PRISON SYSTEM WHICH IS BUILT ON
PUNISHMENT RATHER THAN
REHABILITATION?
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO CHANGE SO
AGAIN IF WE THINK.
JUST IN THAT NARROW CONTEXT OF
MOVING DJJ INTO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
I WE REALLY MISS SOMETHING IF WE
RE THANK WHAT THE BROADER SYSTEM
IS AND THIS IS WHERE.
I KNOW THE LA -- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE LOOKING AT PUTTING SOME
MONEY AND I THINK THIS IS.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT THIS
TRAILER BILL THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT SOME MONEY INTO THE SYSTEM.
TO TO REDESIGN HOW ALL OF THOSE
COMPONENTS WORK TOGETHER WE CAN
ADDRESS AND COVER A LOT MORE
GROUND.
AND THAT IT SHOULD BE DRIVEN BY
THE JUSTICE SIDE OF THINGS FOR
KIDS WHO HAVE MADE A MISTAKE BUT
DRIVEN BY THE THE NEED THAT OUR
FAMILIES HAVE IN OUR CHILDREN
HAVE.
SO THAT THEY DON'T END UP JUST
AS ABOUT THAT THEY DON'T END UP
REMOVED FROM THEIR FAMILIES THEY
DON'T END UP WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS IN THE
SITUATIONS THAT THEY HAVE.
AND THEN WE CAN DEAL WITH EACH
KID AS THEIR NEED AS THEY AS
THEY GO.
THAT'S TO ME WAS WHAT WAS
EXCITED ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S THE STEP I THINK WE CAN
TAKE.
IF WE DO THAT BUT IF WE IF WE
ALL WE'RE GONNA DO IS LIMIT
OURSELVES MOVING DJJ AND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WE MISS THAT.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS THINK
THIS THROUGH A LITTLE BIT AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE CEDING.
THAT WE ARE INVESTING IN A
SIGNIFICANT SYSTEMS CHANGE WITH
THE SYSTEM TO CHANGE ISN'T JUST
DJJ THE SYSTEM TO CHANGE
SERVICES FOR KIDS.
AND THEN THERE IS A COMPONENT OF
IT WHERE WE MAY NEED TO DEAL
WITH THE REHABILITATIVE AND WITH
THAT THE THE MISTAKE IT THAT A
KID HAS MADE.
SOLVE THAT HELP SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM FOR THEM AND FOR THAT
COMMUNITY VENN WHETHER THEY'VE
BAD REMOVED FROM A FAMILY
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN HOMELESS
WHETHER THEY'VE BAD TRAFFIC.
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN JUSTICE
INVOLVED.
FIND WAYS TO GET THEM BACK INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES IN A
PRODUCTIVE HEALTHY WAY THAT THAT
HELPS THEM BREAK THE CYCLES THAT
HAVE LED THEM TO WHERE THEY ARE.
SO LET'S.
AIM HIGH LET'S REALLY LOOK AT
ALL THE SYSTEMS THAT WE USE TO
SUPPORT KIDS WHICH I KNOW
UNFORTUNATE GOES A LITTLE BIT.
ON THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE THE
WAY WE HAVE BROKEN UP.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THAT'S GOING
TO BE.
INTERESTING BUT I THINK WE CAN
DO THAT AND WITH WITH A WOMAN
GOVERNOR AND WITH.
OUTSIDE I KNOW THIS COVER WILL
TAPE IT EIGHT YEARS AHEAD OF US.
TO REALLY BE ABLE TO LOOK HARD
AT THE SYSTEM.
WE COULD DO SOMETHING EVEN MORE
AND THAT'S WHAT I HOPE WE CAN
ULTIMATELY GET TO SO AS WE HAVE
THE NEXT FEW CONVERSATIONS
AROUND.
THIS PROPOSAL THIS SPECIFIC
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE TO DO
SOMETHING HERE BUT WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH YOUR DEPARTMENTS.
AND THINK A LITTLE BIT MORE
BROADLY WITH ALL OF THE
RESOURCES THAT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES CAN BRING. TO BEAR
WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH HE'S BRINGING THAT
INTO THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM AND OTHER PIECES THAT.
THAT NEED TO WORK BETTER
TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF
THAT'S WHAT SHOULD BE REALLY
EXCITING AND GIVE US A MUCH
BETTER OPPORTUNITY TO TO ADDRESS
ISSUES FOR OUR KIDS AND OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITY SO
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK THAT'S
WORTHY OF ALL OF US WORKING
TOGETHER ON MAKING SURE WE GET.
THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO TABLE GET
THE RIGHT DECISIONS MADE AND
KIND OF BREAK DOWN THE THE THE
SILOS THE BARRIERS TO BEING ABLE
TO WORK ACROSS DISCIPLINES WHICH
WE'RE NOT OFFICE AT GOOD DOING
BUT IF WE CAN DO THAT.
THEN WE CAN SERVE KIDS MUCH
BETTER AND I THINK THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THE THE LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL FOR ALL OF US A
REALLY HAPPY TO SEE YOU HERE.
AND HAVE THIS COVERAGE IS A
REALLY START OFFICE CONVERSATION
BUT WE COULD BE.
WE COULD BE ON SOMETHING HERE
THAT REALLY IMPROVES OUR
COMMUNITIES IN A BIG WAY.
MRS JONES SAWYER.
NOT THE HOUSE WHEN IT THANK YOU --
BUT I WAS ALSO VERY EXCITED --
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
BECAUSE WE ACT WE CAN'T
CONTINUES TO SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND EXPECTING
DIFFERENT.
RESULTS [inaudible]
BOB.
BUT ALSO LIKE TO SEE A VISION.
NOT JUST MOVED CHAIRS ON THE
TITANIC.
THAT WE ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
AND THAT -- I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
THE GOVERNOR'S VISION ON HOW YOU
WANT.
THIS TO LOOK ULTIMATELY -- RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE OUT THERE.
THE WAY THE SYSTEM IS -- BUT
BASICALLY TRAINING THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THESE ANY GLADIATOR
CAMPS BECOME BETTER CRIMINALS
WILL BECOME BETTER.
PERSONS TO GO ON TO PRESENTS AND
BECOME BETTER PRISONERS AND AND
BE INCARCERATED FOR THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE.
AND WE HAVE NOT DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB.
IN THE EXISTING SYSTEM RIGHT NOW --
PART OF THAT IS A CULTURAL THING.
THAT WHAT YOU'RE ALL IN THAT
SAME SILO BECAUSE YOU KNOW
GOVERNMENT AND I'M VERY FAMILIAR
GOVERNMENT WHAT YOU'RE IN THAT
SILO.
YOU IS REALLY HARD TO GET OUT OF
IT IN NEW ALL BECOME KIND OF THE
SAME [inaudible]
AND ALMOST LIKE A SCHOOL SYSTEM
YOU.
YOU GO FROM ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TO
THE JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL YOU'RE IN
THE SAME NEIGHBORHOOD TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND YOU REALLY NEVER GET OUT OF
OF WHERE WHAT YOU USED.
TO AND SO -- I WANT IS I WANT TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
[inaudible]
WHAT?
THE DIVISION IS FOR THIS AND IF
THAT INCLUDES HAVING US HERE
HELP YOU WITH THAT VISION.
WE SHOULD OTHERWISE I I THINK
BOTH FINANCE AND AND AND LA --
URBAN CONSTANTLY BE FRUSTRATED
ABOUT COME OUT WITH A NUMBER.
DON'T KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING YOU
KNOW WE START ORGANIZATIONS WE
ASK FOR MISSION STATEMENT AND
ALL OF THAT BUT WE HAVE AN ASK
FOR MISSION STATEMENT HERE WE
HAVE ASKED FOR WHAT IS OUR
ULTIMATE VISION WE HAVE NOBODY'S
GIVEN US.
ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT THIS LOOKS
LIKE WE JUST SAID.
MOVE CHAIRS OVER HERE.
AND HOPE FOR A BETTER RESULT --
I ALSO.
HAVE BEEN USING.
THE TERM AT PROMISE.
BECAUSE AGAIN WE'VE GOT TO LOOK
AT THE KIDS DIFFERENTLY -- IF WE
KEEP CALLING -- JUVENILES
JUVENILE DELINQUENCY CALLING HIM
AT RISK WE KEEP CALLING NAMES
LIKE THAT.
THEN THEY WILL ACT APPROPRIATELY.
IF YOU TELL THEM THERE'S A
FUTURE FOR THEM THAT'S A PROMISE
TO THEM THEY WILL GET BETTER.
AND WHEN I MEET PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN DJJ.
TELL ME THAT.
I NEED TO ME AS A AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL I NEED TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
THEIR ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO USE --
PEPPER SPRAY BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
THOSE KIDS ARE REALLY REALLY BAD.
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT WE GO
THROUGH BUT THERE'S SOMETHING.
WRONG WHEN THE STAFF
[inaudible]
ITSELF.
IS KIND OF CRIMINALIZING
CRIMINALIZING THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND SO I I WOULD ALSO TELL YOU
IF YOU CAN A BILL THAT SHE GOT A
BILL THAT FROM HER.
GROUND UP I BELIEVE YOU CAN
BUILD IT WITH THE EXISTING STAFF
BUT THOSE THAT DON'T SHARE THE
VALUES THE VISION -- ABOUT WHO
YOU MIGHT BE TIME FOR THEM
RETIRE.
IT MIGHT BE TIME FOR THEM TO TO
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS NEW
SYSTEM WE'RE BUILDING IS GOING
IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE STAFF IS THE ONE THAT WOULD
FIT IN ONCE IT WILL IMPLEMENT
THIS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THEM ON BOARD.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THEM FULLY
BEHIND YOU ALL ORDERS ROWING AT
THE SAME TIME.
YOU WILL REPLACE THIS WITH THE
SAME D. J. J. THAT YOU HAVE NOW
ONLY IT'S IN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
YOU JUST MOVED THE CHAIRS WHEN
YOU DECIDED TO TENT.
AND SO I WOULD URGE YOU TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
YOU WANT TO WORK IN THESE
FACILITIES.
NOW TO GET BY IN THE GET THEIR
INPUT HOW.
YOUR YOUR VISION IS.
SO THAT YOU HAVE THE SOLDIERS
WITH YOU -- TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
AND AND THEN FINALLY -- WHAT TWO
THINGS?
ONE WORKING WITH THE JUVENILE
COURTS.
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THEY PLAY A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THIS THE
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE -- MAKE
MAYBE COMING YOUR WAY ARE NOT
COMING YOUR WAY DO WE DO IT IN
THE TO DO IT AND COMMUNITY.
DO YOU BRING THEM.
INTO THIS SETTING OF THE
JUVENILE COURTS ARE THE THE
OTHER ONES ARE GOING TO GUIDE A
LOT OF THIS AND SO WE NEED TO
HAVE A US A SERIOUS CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT AND LOOK AT THE DATA
WE HAVE.
AN ULTIMATE OVERSIGHT OF ALL OF
THAT.
AND FINALLY THIS WORD CALLED
FROM.
TRUMP IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
AS I'VE GOT DUPES SEVERAL UP
PRISONS -- MEETING WITH ADULT
PRISONERS YOU DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY OF THEM HAVE TOLD ME.
SOME REALLY HORRIFIC THINGS THAT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCE OF CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA.
THAT -- I CALL PUSH BACKSTREET
DISORDER BECAUSE WHAT GOES ON
THE STREETS SOMETIME MUCH WORSE
TOMATOES ON IN WAR.
AND THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SPRING SOME THINGS THAT YOU AND
I IF IT HAPPENED TO US.
WE HAVE TO SEE SEEK MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS -- TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH IT AND
SNEEZE AT LIKE FIVE YEAR OLD
SECURE -- SEVEN YEAR OLD AND
THEN WE EXPECT THEM. TO GROW OUT
OF IT OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
AND SO -- IT MADE ME MORE MONEY
[inaudible]
DâN.
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
OF THE TABLE MAY BE LOOKING AT
BECAUSE IT'S A WHOLE SYSTEM OF
CARE.
THAT WE MAY BE LOOKING AT AND
NOT JUST -- WHERE CAN WE PUT
THEM?
UNTIL THEY GET BETTER.
NOW WHERE CAN WE PUT THEM SO
THEY CAN RECEIVE THE SERVICES
AND A THE HELP THAT THEY NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD.
AND AGAIN I I THINK PART OF THE
THE FUNDING PROBLEM IN THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE HAVING HERE.
IS WHAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
VISION.
AND SO.
THEY LIKE I APOLOGIZE CAME A
LITTLE LATE MAYBE YOU DID SHARE
YOUR VISION OF WHAT THIS LOOKS
LIKE.
I KNOW SUMMERTIME IS IS REALLY
MACRO BUT I LIKE TO GET IN TWO
WEEKS -- OF WHAT.
TYPE OF A PERSON WILL BE.
TAKING CARE TO YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT TYPE OF PROFESSIONS
WOULD DEPRIVE SKILL SETS WITH
THE WHAT DO WE NEED. TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN NOT JUST THE
PHYSICAL.
BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN BILL LET
pIMPORTANT THING WHAT GOES ON
INSIDE.
SO I AM A I'M I'M HOPING THAT I
CAN GET.
OR WITH THIS COMMITTEE AT LEAST
CAN GET SOME SOME UNDERSTANDING
OF OF WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH
THIS SO THAT WHEN WE DO VOTE.
AND WE DO PUT MONEY TOWARDS THIS
IS GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WE DON'T HAVE TO MAKE A WHOLE
OTHER JUST MONTHS LATER
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO CAME
TODAY THANKS SO THOSE OF YOU WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CONVERSATION --
I THINK WHEN WE ALL HEARD THAT
OF THIS RECOMMENDATION AND THE
EARLY PART OF THE YEAR WE WERE
CONCERNED THAT THERE WAS NOT --
THE WE HAD NOT DO NOT HAVE SI A
PLAN.
BUT WHAT WE SAW WAS JUST A
STATEMENT THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITHOUT ANY REAL.
IDEA OF HOW LONG IT WOULD TAKE
WHETHER THEY BE A THOROUGH
PROCESS ALL THOUGHTFUL PROCESS
IN DOING THIS AND OF OF WE JUST
GOT THE RECOMMENDATION LAST
FRIDAY.
SO WE HAVEN'T EVEN HAD A CHANCE
TO REALLY THAT THAT BECAUSE WE
WERE ON BREAK. FOR THE LAST WEEK
SO WE'VE HAD NOT HAD A CHANCE TO
REALLY THOROUGHLY LOOK AT THE
PROPOSAL WHICH WE WILL DO.
AND LOOK AT WITH REGARDS TO WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
MOST OF OUR CONCERNS LEASE MY
CONCERN INITIALLY WAS AS MANY OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE SAID ALREADY.
THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE JUST A
SIMPLE PLACEMENT OF ONE
INSTITUTION INTO A OF UNDER THE
OFF UP UNDER THE CONTROL OF
ANOTHER INSTITUTION -- THAT NOT
THAT THAT OF THE INSTITUTION IS
ALL THAT GREAT YOU KNOW I MEAN
SO AS A RESULT IT YOU KNOW THE
IMPLICATION OBVIOUSLY WAS THAT
THIS SHOULD BE A CHANGE IN.
PHILOSOPHY OF HOW WE OPERATE AND
WHAT WE HANDLE AND HOW WE DEAL
WITH IT IN HOW WE VIEW.
THE THE ACTIVITIES OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN IN CALIFORNIA AND AND
AND THAT'S AND SEE AN RESULTS I
A I A PROBLEMS.
WITH WITH ALL OF THE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE -- IN
TERMS OF HOW WE OPERATE PERIOD
I'D YOU KNOW AND WHEN YOU TELL
ME THAT IT'S AN ATMOSPHERE OF
FEAR AND INTIMIDATION AND
VIOLENCE -- IT'S NOT ONLY IN
THERE BUT IT'S THROUGHOUT OUR
OTHER SYSTEMS AS WELL I FIND IT
APPALLING.
OF THAT WE TOLERATE THE LEVEL OF
VIOLENCE IN OUR SYSTEMS AND THAT
WE BRAG ABOUT IT.
AND I SAY WHEN I SAY BRAG ABOUT
IT I MEAN THE SEXUAL ASSAULT --
ON EACH OTHER THE PHYSICAL
ASSAULT ON EACH OTHER IN IN
WITHIN THE INSTITUTIONS YOU KNOW
SOMEONE GOING ANSWERS ALL YOU'RE
GOING TO BE SO AND SO'S
GIRLFRIEND WHEN YOU GET THERE.
THAT'S A STATEMENT ABOUT SEXUAL
ASSAULT THAT EVEN IF WE MAKE
THAT STATEMENT EITHER IN COURT
OR IN IN IN IN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT THIS IS WE TOLERATE
THIS WE TOLERATE THIS LEVEL OF
VIOLENCE.
THAT OCCURS AND IT BOTHERS ME
BECAUSE THESE ARE HUMAN BEINGS
AND THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WANT TO REHABILITATE WILL BRING
THEM BACK INTO SOCIETY THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO DO IS TAKE A
MENTAL PLACE IS GOING TO MAKE
THEM EVEN MORE VICTIMS.
MORE DEFENSIVE AND FIGHT MORE SO
I MEAN SO THIS IS I THINK WE
HAVE A A WAYS TO GO IN TERMS OF
THE THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THIS NATION
PERIOD IS THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE
SYSTEM.
THAT IS BASICALLY PUNITIVE AND
PEOPLE INTEREST AND BECOME WORSE
RATHER THAN BETTER AND MOST MOST
OF THEM UNLESS THEY HAVE A VERY
STRONG FAMILY THAT INTERVENES
THE ONES I'VE SEEN HAVE COME OUT.
A VERY VERY STRONG FAMILIES AND
OF INTERVENE AND AND AND TRIED
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THAT
PERSON'S LIFE WHICH IS NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
BUT IF IT RELIES UPON THE SYSTEM
TO REHABILITATE THEM THEN IT
GENTLY DOESN'T HAPPEN IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN -- I WAS IN ANY EVENT
YESTERDAY AND IN LOS ANGELES --
VISITING WITH FAMILY SAID IN A
DINNER AND I HAD JUST INQUIRED
OF SOME YOUNG PEOPLE AND I THINK
ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE BUT THEY'RE
MY EAST NOW.
BUT THE LITTLE BIT YOUNGER AS TO
WHERE ARE THEY AND THESE ARE
KIDS WHO HAD -- OF FRIENDS SOME
FAMILY MEMBERS AND OTHERS WHO
HAD OFTEN BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND I
WANT TO KNOW WHERE THEY WORK.
WHAT WERE THEY DOING I WASN'T
THINKING ABOUT COMING ITS
MEETING I JUST WAS CONCERNED
BECAUSE I HADN'T SEEN HIM IN
AWHILE?
AND NOT A ONE OF THEM WAS DOING
WELL.
NOT A ONE OF THOSE WHO WEREN'T
INCARCERATED WERE IN SEVERE PAIN
HEALTH ISSUES.
OF WHERE THEY WERE -- YOU KNOW
IN THEIR LATE FORTIES EARLY
FIFTIES AND YET IN WITH AND
CONVALESCENT HOMES.
I HAVE WERE VICTIMS OBVIOUSLY A
CONSTANT SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND AS
A RESULT IT HAD DESTROYED MUCH
OF THE IMMUNE SYSTEMS AS WELL AS
A HOST OF OTHER THINGS.
SO NOT A PERSON NOT A ONCE IT
THIS PERSON IS DOING REALLY WELL.
EVERY LAST ONE OF THEM HAD SOME
PROBLEMS OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND PHYSICAL HEALTH
PROBLEM.
AND IT WAS REALLY QUITE SAD THAT
I REMEMBER THEM AS CHILDREN --
GETTING INVOLVED IN LITTLE
ACTIVITIES AND DOING THINGS THAT
WERE WRONG -- AND NOW AS I LOOK
AT THEIR LIVES AT THE AFTER
FORTY FIFTY YEARS.
AND WHATEVER HAPPENED IN THE
PROCESS OF ALL THESE ACTIVITIES
NOTHING TURNED OUT GOOD.
NOTHING NOT A PERSON SAID TO ME
ABOUT ANY OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW.
OF THERE WAS SOME RELATIVES AND
SOME FRIENDS THAT THEIR LIVES
ARE BETTER.
THAT THEY JUST LIVING A NORMAL
LIFE EVERY LAST ONE OF THEM WAS
UNDER THE CARE OF SOMEONE ELSE
FOR SOME HEALTH PHYSICAL HEALTH.
OR MENTAL HEALTH SITUATION AND
ONE WAS INCARCERATED.
AND IT WAS ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT AND I WE
WAS SO SAD -- TO REMEMBER THESE
THE THIS THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
TO KNOW THE NOT A ONE HEADED
GOOD OUTCOME.
AS A RESULT OF BEING IN THE
SYSTEMS THEIR WHOLE LIVES AND SO
IT'S REALLY QUITE SAD FOR ME I
MEAN I LEFT THAT EVENT JUST
REALLY DEPRESSED.
AND IT YET THOUGH A LOT OF OLD
FOLKS ABOUT WAS DOING EXTREMELY
WELL.
BUT THOSE OF THAT I REMEMBER WHO
WERE VICTIMS OF A WHOLE LOT OF
DRAMA IN THEIR LIVES -- WITH
THIS FROM THE FAMILIES OF REAL
IS WHATEVER IT WAS A SCHOOL OF
MANY OF THEM WERE COSTLY TAUNTED
AT SCHOOL AND KICKED OUT ALL THE
TIME AND NOT UNDERSTOOD THAT
THEY AT ISSUES.
NOTHING GOOD CAME FROM THEM NONE
OF THEM EVER FINISHED HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND THEY ALL HAD SEVERE MENTAL
OR PHYSICAL PROBLEMS AND IT
BOTHERED ME SO THAT I TOLD MY
SISTER I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO
VISIT THEM WHEN I GO BACK TO LA.
AND JUST SEE IF IS THIS LATE IN
LIFE IF I COULD TAKE A LUNCH OR
DINNER OR SOMETHING I MEAN.
IT WAS VERY VERY TRAUMATIC FOR
ME TO UNDERSTAND THAT AND I
REALIZE THAT THIS IS THE PRODUCT.
OF THE SYSTEM THAT I THINK
CLINTON SAID LONG TIME AGO
SYSTEMS CANNOT RAISE CHILDREN.
FAMILIES RAISE CHILDREN.
AND WE SAID THAT WHEN CLINTON
WAS PRESIDENT AND WE STILL ARE
TRYING TO LET SYSTEMS RAISE
CHILDREN OR SOMEONE SAID TO ME
ONCE WHEN WE WERE TALKING THEY
SAID ALL THE KIDS ARE WE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH.
OUR WERE ONCE ARE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE COUNTIES
OF OF THE STATE BECAUSE ALL OF
THEM HAVE SOME KIND OF SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCY INVOLVED IN THEIR
LIVES.
AND SO IN SO WE HAVE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY HERE I I WENT TO
I WAS IN GHANA ONCE FOR PROGRAM
JUST TO VISIT AND I WHEN I GO I
KNOW ME TRIED TO SOME GOOD ONE
ON THERE.
AND THEN JUST VACATION.
AND I WENT TO A JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM A PROGRAM.
AND YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW IT
DRIVING DOWN THE STREET IT WAS
LIKE A BIG HOUSE SEVERAL HOUSES.
ON IN THIS BLOCK AND THERE WAS
NO GATE NOBODY LOCKED UP SO FOR
THE SOMEONE.
AND THEY WERE NUMBER OF YOUNG
LADIES IN THIS IN THIS FACILITY
AND THEIR PHILOSOPHY WAS THAT
THESE KIDS HAVE DONE SOMETHING
WRONG.
BECAUSE THEIR FAMILIES AND THE
SOCIETY HAVE FAILED THEM.
AND SO THEIR TASK WAS TO TRY TO
RE BILL.
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
CHILDREN AND THE FAMILIES.
THEIR ANSWER UNCLES AND COUSINS
OF WHATEVER AND TO REBUILD THE
SOME PEOPLE TO THE STRUCTURE OF
THE FAMILY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE DOING
OF THE THE KIDS WERE TAKING
CLASSES THEY WERE LEARNING.
TO SO WHEN I WENT TO WINS
WOMEN'S THING THEY WERE LEARNING
IS A SKILLED IN A TRADE TO SO.
THEY HAD SOME COUNSELORS THEIR
THEIR FAMILIES VISITED THEM
OFTEN.
YOU KNOW AND THAT WAS COUNSELING
FOR FAMILIES TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IT WHAT IT WHAT WAS THERE
BECAUSE THEIR PHILOSOPHY WAS.
IN THIS SOCIETY THE GOOD NAY
INSISTS THAT IT THAT IS THE
FAMILY THAT'S THE CENTER.
OF EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS AND
AND YOU STRENGTH IN THAT FAMILY
AND THOSE RELATIVES IN THE
CONNECTION THAT'S THERE AND THAT
THE FAMILY HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
FOR CHILDREN.
AND WHEN WHEN THINGS GO AWRY
THEY DO THEIR BEST TO TRY TO
REBUILD THOSE FAMILIES.
AND SO I WENT TO A WOMEN'S
FACILITY AND THEN I WENT TO ONE
I SHOULDN'T SAY A FACILITY
BECAUSE REALLY WASN'T AND THEN I
WENT TO ONE OF WITH THE HEAD
MALES.
TOTALLY DIFFERENT VIEW OF HOW
YOU DEAL WITH WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MADE MISTAKES.
AND SO I THOUGHT I'D I LEFT THE
THINK IN WOW YOU KNOW THIS IS A
WORLD AWAY FROM US YEAH THIS IS
WOULD BE CONSIDERED A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY.
DEALING WITH ITS OWN CHILDREN
AND WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO TRY
TO REBUILD THOSE LIVES FOR THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE FAMILIES
THAT ARE CENTRAL TO THAT.
SO WE HAVE GOT I I I AGREE WITH
MY STAFF WE NEED TO HAVE A
PHILOSOPHY ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO -- I WHAT I AM STILL
CONCERNED THAT WOULD THERE HAVE
THERE HAS NOT BEEN ENOUGH
ONGOING CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THE VARIOUS ENTITIES AND THE
FINANCES AS TO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING TALKING ABOUT BUILDING
IT'S ONE THING TO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE IT.
IT'S ANOTHER THING TO TALK ABOUT
WHERE YOU WILL MOVE IT TO WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAT YOU MOVE IT TO
WHETHER THIS IS A JOINT
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AT
SOME POINT A PUBLIC SAFETY
WHETHER THEY'D RATHER THAN JUST
SHIFTING FROM ONE TO THE OTHER
THAN DISCOVERING THAT WOULD
TOTALLY INADEQUATE BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE SOME SERVICES WE HAD
OVER HERE.
THAT WE NEED OVER THERE AND SO I
I I'M HOPING AND AND CONFIDENT
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE SOME IN
DEPTH CONVERSATION -- I DON'T
PLAN DOUBLE FOR A MOVE OF
ANYTHING THAT IS NOT US SO I
THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
SOME TIME OR US TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
WITH THE ADVOCATES AS WELL AS
WITH THOSE IN FINANCE I'M MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT EVER BECAUSE AND
FINANCE BECAUSE I FIGURED IF WE
LIKE IT AND WE LOVE IT WILL FUND
YOU KNOW IT'S ALMOST KIND OF
THING SO.
I'M NOT IS IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FINANCIAL PIECE I GUESS YOU
GUYS WILL TELL US WHAT IT COST
US AND SO FORTH AND SO ON BIGGER
BUT BECAUSE MY BELIEF IS THAT IF
WE DO IT AND WOOD RIGHT.
EVEN IF IT COSTS US MORE IN THE
FRONT AND IT WILL COST US LESS
ON THE BACK.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DID NOT TRYING
TO MAKE PERMANENT CRIMINALS AND
A PERMANENT COST.
OF THIS THERE'S STILL THAT EVEN
IF IT'S IF IT'S IF IT COSTS US
MORE IN THE IN THE BENEFITS THAT
WE REAP TO HAVING.
ACTIVE PRODUCTIVE OF RESPONSIBLE
CITIZENS CONTRIBUTING TO THE
LIFE OF CALIFORNIA IS FAR BETTER
THAN HAVING A PIPELINE TO THE
BIGGEST PRISON THAT WE CAN FIND
FOR THEM -- IN TERMS OF THE COST
THAT'S THERE AND SO FORTH AS
WELL AS A SPENDING A FORTUNE
RIGHT NOW.
ON JUVENILE JUSTICE AND AND YOU
KNOW THE MOUNT PEOPLE TELL ME WE
SPEND I COULD TAKE A FAMILY
GIVEN AND MONEY THEY GET A HOUSE.
AND LIVE GOOD EATEN AND MAYBE
TAKE EVERYBODY YOU KNOW THAT
KIND OF STUFF I MEAN REALITY IS
WHAT WE'VE BEEN A ONE THESE KIDS
THEIR FAMILIES DON'T MAKE.
IT AS AS INCOME AND SO THAT IN
ITSELF IS FRIGHTENING -- TO YEAH
YOU KNOW THEIR FAMILIES -- MAKE
TO A FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR AND AND SO AS A RESULT WE
COULD PROBABLY A WHOLE LOT
BETTER TO REBUILD FAMILIES AND
LIVES -- WITH THIS RATHER THAN
WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING BUT
BUT I'M OPTIMISTIC I'M GOING TO
BE THE OPTIMIST IN THE ROOM
ALWAYS.
THAT IF WE WANT TO DO SOMETHING
DO IT RIGHT WELL IT TAKES TIME --
IT TAKES COMMITMENT WE HAVE A
LOT OF FOLKS IN LINE WHO GOES
GIVE US THEIR DEFINITION -- JUST
THE ONE STATEMENT OF WHO THEY
ARE AND WHERE THEY'RE FROM --
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A
LONG TIME.
SOMETIMES BY THEMSELVES AGAINST
THE INSTITUTIONS THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED -- BUT I THINK WE ARE
HEADED IN THE GOOD DIRECTION AND
I THINK AS LONG AS WITH BIT. TO
MAKING SURE THAT -- THAT WE
REALLY HAVE A VISION OF
SOMETHING COME TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
THAN WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE I
THINK WE'LL BE FINE WE'LL BE
FINE SOMEONE MOST BRILLIANT KIDS
OF A MATTER IN OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH IS
SOMETIMES FRIGHTENING TO ME.
HOW SMART THEY ARE AND AND AND --
AND I THINK SOMETIMES THAT'S WHY
THEY THEY ARE BECAUSE THEY'RE SO
SMART THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHAT TO
DO WITH THE SO THIS IS WHAT THIS
IS HOW THEY HANDLE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE A NUMBER
PURCHASE A WANT TO GIVE US THEIR
NAME.
AND WITH A FAVORABLE TO POSTED
WHAT ORGANIZATION AND WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE TIME FOR LONG.
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH SO THAT
MOST OF YOUR INVOLVED IN SOME OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS AND IF YOUR
ORGANIZATION WILL ASK YOU TO
GIVE SOME INPUT.
SO IF YOU WANT TO GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND TELL US WHAT YOU AND
FAVORITE UP OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSAL YES I'M HELEN ROTH
DELTON.
FROM SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
RIVERA WE REPRESENT THE
CUSTODIANS THE KITCHEN WORKERS
THE TEACHERS AND THE NURSES AND
HEALTH PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THESE
FACILITIES.
WERE NOT OPPOSED TO THIS WHAT WE
ARE AS WERE WORRIED ABOUT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WELL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR IS TO
MOVE MORE PEOPLE FROM ACTUALLY
THE ADULT PRISONS.
INTO THE JUVENILE A PRINT
PRISONS WHERE WE THINK THERE'S A
LOT MORE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
THERE'S A LOT MORE SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED FOR EXAMPLE KIDS
WANT A LOT OF THAT BUT WE KNOW
YOUR POSITION AND ALSO WHAT OUR
POSITION AS WE WANT TO WORK WITH
ALL OF YOU.
BUT WE WANT YOU TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN TAKE AND KEEP THESE
FACILITIES SO THEY'RE AVAILABLE
AND THEY CAN PROVIDE
REHABILITATION.
AND WE DON'T THINK WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE WITH SOME OF THE
PEOPLE HAVE DONE THIS BUT WE
THINK THAT WE WERE ARE GOING TO
THE MEETING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND GOING TO BE WORKING
WITH THEM ON THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
GEORGE GOT TO BE SOME --
FOUNDING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COURAGE COMMUNITY FOR SORT OF
YOUTH JUSTICE AND A MEMBER OF
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS MEN OF
COLOR AND A STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LIGHTS FOR YOU
THINK ME JUSTICE -- WE SUPPORT
THIS AND ARE ALSO AT THE SAME
TIME COSTS THE OPTIMISTIC -- WE
ECHO A LOT OF THE CONCERNS ARE
EXPRESSED BY.
OTHER FOLKS I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO BE ON A PROJECT ABOUT A NOR
STAR IN THAT THE MORE CONTACT
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE WITH SYSTEMS
THE WORST OUTCOMES ARE FOR THEM
AND I DON'T WANT TO GET.
CAUGHT UP INTO A PARADIGM TO
CHINA HUMANIZING CREATE A MORE
PERFECT CAGEY CAGES CAGE NO
MATTER WHAT IN THE END GOAL
NEEDS TO BE WE CAN HAVE CAGE
FREE CHICKENS CAN WE HAVE CAGE
FREE KIDS IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SUPER RALPH FROM THE
PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER
I HAVE THE DISTINCTION OF HAVING
BEEN ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE TRIED TO
KEEP.
OF THE STATE FROM PUTTING DJJ IN
THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM TO BEGIN
WITH SO I'M VERY HAPPY THAT ODD
THIS IS BEEN PROPOSED.
BY THE GOVERNOR OF MY
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTS THE TO THE
MOVE TO HHS AND WOULD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE REMARKS OF MISTER
SUPPLE AND DOCTOR GALLEY.
BUT IF THIS IS ONLY A PIECE OF
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND WE HOPE
THAT THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
YOU WILL SET INTO MOTION THE
BROADER JUVENILE JUSTICE CHANGES
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN WHICH HAVE
BEEN REFERENCED BY NUMBER OF THE
SPEAKERS TODAY THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
SASHI LARIOS I'M A FULL TIME
COLLEGE STUDENT I ALSO WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE COURAGE.
AND I'M ALSO THE VERY FIRST
YOUTH JUSTICE A YOUTH
COMMISSIONER BACK AT JUVENILE
HALL AND ALL THEY WANT TO SAVE
TO YOU GUYS.
IS TO INVEST THE COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES BECAUSE I AM AN
EXCEPTION TO THE SYSTEM AND WE
DON'T NEED CAGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TATUM VOLUME
WITHOUT COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
SORT OF YOUTH JUSTICE AND I'M
ALSO FORMALLY INCARCERATED
MYSELF -- I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BUT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT IS JUST A FIRST
STEP ON THE ROAD TO CLOSING
YOUTH PRISONS AND BUILDING YOUTH
LEADERS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAURIE DELPHIAN
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY WITH
THE W. HE WOULD BURNS INSTITUTE.
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SHIFT BUT ONE WITH KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP OF A MUCH
BIGGER PROCESS THAT ENCOMPASSES
A MUCH BROADER VISION FOR YOUTH
JUSTICE TRANSFORMATION.
CHANGING G. SHIFTING DJJ FROM
CDC ART HHS WILL NOT DO ANYTHING
TO ADDRESS STRUCTURAL RACISM
SYSTEMIC BIAS SEIZE OR THE
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS THAT ARE
JUST REALLY IMPACTING YOUTH OF
COLOR.
AND IT RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES AT
THE DEEPEST AND OF OUR SYSTEM.
COMPARED TO WHITE YOUTH BLACK
YOUTH ARE MORE THAN TWELVE TIMES
AS LIKELY TO BE COMMITTED TO DJJ.
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH ARE ALMOST
FIVE TIMES AS LIKELY AND LATINO
YOUTH ARE ALMOST THREE TIMES AS
LIKELY WE NEED A MORE HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
THAT IS CENTERED IN EQUITY.
THAT RESOURCES COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES AND THANK YOU THANK
YOU I'M GOING TO ENCOURAGE YOU
GUYS TO BE REALLY REALLY SHORT.
BECAUSE I KNOW MOST OF THE YOU
HAVE SOME GREAT IDEAS AND I'M
HOPING THAT YOU ORGANIZATIONS
WILL PARTICIPATE WITH THE GROUP
THAT'S HERE.
YES YES MY NAME IS JOSEPH GRAY
ON THE SECOND A DIRECTOR WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
ORGANIZATION OF MYSELF OR
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THIS MOVE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT WAS ROUTED
AND EQUALITY AND HOPE FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MARK FILL
PART WITH POLICY LINK IN THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR.
WE ARE IN A STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS TRANSITION -- AND ALSO SEE
IT AS A FIRST STEP TOWARDS THE
CLOSURE OF YOUTH PRISONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON ATTACHMENTS FOR
ON BEHALF OF THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSED MOVE
BUT WE BELIEVE IT IS CRITICAL
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE
STEPS. TO ADDRESS THE GROWING
POPULATION OF DJJ IN ORDER FOR
THE MOVE TO BE SUCCESSFUL I
THINK IT'S CONCERNING THAT
DURING THIS ENTIRE CONVERSATION
THERE'S BEEN NO MENTION OF THE
FACT THAT THE POPULATION IS
GROWING AT DJJ.
AND THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
ASKING FOR MORE STAFF WE BELIEVE
IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE FOR THE
MOVE TO CONTINUE AS PROJECTED
WITHOUT ANY STEPS BEING TAKEN TO
STABILIZE THE POPULATION AND
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT.
SIMPLY GROWING A BIGGER CAGE
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS OLIVER MERYL I
REPRESENT THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION A LIFE COACH.
I FULLY SUPPORT REMOVING DJJ.
FROM UNDER THE JURISDICTION IS
CDC ARE AS IT WILL PROMOTE
REHABILITATION AND I'M FULLY
SUPPORT OF THE TEN BY TEN
COALITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN GOLDSTINE
WITH THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ON WHY WE
SUPPORT THE MOVE WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT DJJ THE
VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA WITHIN THE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND WOULD HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD CONSIDER GREATER
OVERSIGHT INVESTMENT AND MOVING
AWAY FROM THIS FAILING STATE
SYSTEM THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL DOES WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
AND WE STRONG SUPPORT THIS MOVE
WILD URGING TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
STEPS BASED ON THE TEN BY TEN
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
PECK ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA AND REPRESENT ALL
OF THE APPROBATION CHIEF
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S MOVE FROM THAT
GETTING THE DEPARTMENT OUT OF
THE ADULT PRISON SYSTEM AT
SIMILAR AS TO HOW WE ARE ALSO.
CONSTRUCTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AS IT'S BEEN STATED HERE WE DO --
HAVE A MAJORITY OF OF THE YOUTH
IN OUR CARE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS TO TRY AND LOOK AT
HOW. TO BEST DO THAT THIS IS OF
A HISTORIC SHIFT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT SHIFT AND CAN'T BE
DONE OVERNIGHT AND CAN'T BE DONE
IN SUCH A WAY THAT WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES --
WHERE WE'VE SEEN THE PAST TEN
YEARS 60% DROPS AND -- DETENTION
RATES AND OVER 70% DROPS IN
JUVENILE ARREST RATES AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO CONTINUE
DOWN THAT SAME PATH THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CLAIRE BARBARIAN
I'M HERE WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND I
AGREE WITH THIS A PROPOSAL TO
MOVE THOUGH I DO HOPE IT IS THE
FIRST STEP I WASN'T SEE YA WHEN
IT BECAME WHEN IT WAS STILL SEE
WAY AND BECAME DJJ AND NOTHING.
SIGNIFICANT REALLY CHANGED THEY
THANK YOU.
GOOD I DON'T KNOW WHAT TIME OF
DAY IT IS EVENING OR AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KATIE DIXON I'M A
POLICY FELLOW WITH ELLIS PC AND
ALL OF US ARE NONE -- I AM A
VOICE INSIDE OF THIS REPORT I
WAS SOMEONE THAT THEY WORK WITH
TO GET REAL LIFE EXPERIENCE A
WILL GOALS ON INSIDE OF THE HOME.
SEE YA AND I AM GLAD THAT WE ARE
ALL RECOGNIZING THAT A NAME
CHANGE IS JUST THE NAME CHANGE
WE'VE BEEN CHANGING NAMES.
SINCE I BELIEVE EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE SO ANOTHER NAME CHANGE IS
JUST THE NAME CHANGE.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS CONVERSATION
AGAIN WE SUPPORT THIS MOVE BUT
FEEL LIKE WITHOUT -- I REALLY
SUBSTANTIVE ARE PLANNED FOR
HUSBAND BEFORE THIS LED BY THE
COMMUNITY IT'S UNLIKELY TO
PRODUCE CHANGES EVERYONE IS
SAYING. ONE WHY DO YOU SEE FIRST
GOT INVOLVED IN SHUTTING DOWN
SEE WAY IT WASN'T JUST BECAUSE
OUR MEMBERS HAD BEEN INSIDE BUT
IS BECAUSE ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
DION WITH FIELD.
WAS FOUND HUNG IN HIS CELL AFTER
BEING IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
WITH HIS CELL MATE FOR MONTHS
MANY MANY MONTHS.
I'M NOT HAVING ANY ACCESS TO
EDUCATION OR TO RECREATION OR TO
OUTSIDE ON HUMAN HUMAN --
ATTENTION.
AND IT WAS FOUND NOT LONG AFTER
THEY WERE FONG FOUND HUNG THAT
THEY WERE ALSO ISSUED PROZAC
FROM -- THEN SEE YA -- AND THEN
AFTER THAT THAT THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT FOUND THE PROZAC
DOESN'T WORK WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
AT THAT AGE AS IT DOES WITH
ADULTS ON YOU GIVE US YOUR
POSITION NOW SO I JUST WANT NAME
THESE NAMES BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT REMEMBER THE YOUNG
PEOPLE DIED WITHIN SEE.
YA AND TO SAY AGAIN THAT THIS
CONDITIONS ARE STILL AS A REPORT
ISSUED COMMENTS ON VERY MUCH THE
SAME AS WHEN THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
DIED THERE WAS FIVE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT DIED WITH AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
PERIOD -- DION INJURY ALONG WITH
DIE RUN BREWER REPORTER LONG
BONNELL AND JOSEPH MALDONADO --
SO WE'RE HERE TODAY TO REMEMBER
THEM AND TO URGE THAT WE NEED
NOT ONLY A YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT BUT THE COMMUNITY
TREATMENT CENTERS THAT ARE RUN
BY THE COMMUNITY.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH UNIONS SO
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE LEAVE WITH THE
UNION APPRENTICESHIP IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AGAIN PEOPLE ARE
COLLEGE EDUCATED AND LEAVE
ENROLLED IN COLLEGE.
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS
OPPOSED BY CORRECTIONS AND
PROBATION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RUTH
WITH MORE AND OF GRANDPARENTS --
OF THE YOUNG MAN THAT WAS IN THE
YOUTH AUTHORITY.
AND HE WAS SINCE BEFORE HE WAS
TO AS AN ADULT AND IS COMMITTEE
IS PRIME ONE IS FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD.
BUT WHAT I'M HERE SAYS I DO
SUPPORT WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
TRYING TO DO FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THAT AGE GROUP.
AND THAT HOPEFULLY THAT THEY
WILL REMAIN WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY CAN GIVE
SOME FAMILY SUPPORT.
BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES AND NO MY
GRASS AND THEY MOVED HIM WAY
DOWN THE CHINO AND I LIVE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND JUST
THANK GOD I HAD THE FUNDS. TO
FLY OVER THERE AND VISIT MY
GRANDSON IN ANOTHER BAD THING
ABOUT IT PUTTING KIDS FROM THE
SOUTH.
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WASN'T
REALLY A GOOD THING AND IT COST
A LOT OF TRAUMA.
SO I HOPE AND I'M SPEAKING AS
THE GRANDMOTHER WHO'S
EXPERIENCED IT AND AS THE
TAXPAYER.
DE YOU WOULD -- SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN MY NAME IS FOR THIS
ONE I AM A PARENT.
MY SON Y. SOON.
SEE YA DJJ WELL MADE CHANGES AND
I'M SUPPORTING WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAVE.
TO OFFER FOR OUR KIDS HOWEVER.
I THINK THE LEGISLATORS TO TAKE
VERY LOOK AT THIS WHERE DID THIS
MONEY IT'S GOING TO GO IS THERE
REALLY CLINICAL FLORA KITS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SUCH AS MINE.
I WENT THROUGH HELL AND BACK
WITH DJJ WITH MY SON PUT TRIED
TO COMMIT SUICIDE TWICE IT I WAS
NOTIFIED. FOUR DAYS LATER MY SON
WENT TO A LOT OF PUNISHMENT.
SINCE THE AGE OF FIFTEEN AND A
HALF MY SUN THE SIX LONG YEARS.
I CAN BE THERE FOR THREE DAYS.
TO TELL HIS STORY.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
AGE NEVER GOING TO WORK BECAUSE
SOLELY ESCALATE.
FROM JUVENILE HALL.
THE DJTO PRISON IF YOU I'M ME
WHERE MY SON HE'S HE'S DEPRESSED
HE DOESN'T HAVE A JOB WHAT DO
THEY GIVE ME A HAPPY LITTLE BOY
THAT I REYES.
AT THAT TIME I'M A PARENT OF
THREE KIDS THIS IS MY YOUNGEST
ONE HIS FATHER WAS THAT WORK FOR
SOME FIFTIES GO.
COULD YOU SUM IT UP RIGHT ARM.
COPY WHAT THE POLICEMAN.
I ALSO A FORMAL PRESCHOOL
TEACHER.
AND I WON WE I WORK WITH
CHILDREN UNDER PRIVILEGED.
CHILDREN I PRIVILEGED THERE IS A
DIFFERENT TREATMENT -- ARCHED
CHILDREN.
I'D SIENNA HAPPENED SO I'M
HOPING.
THAT YOU CAN FOCUS TO CHANGE FOR
THE BETTER TO PUT OUR KIDS. FOR
REHABILITATION TO PREPARE THEM
FOR JOB BECAUSE ONCE THEY GET
OUT THEY COME BACK BECAUSE THE
SEAT TO DR SYSTEM DOWN A WARRANT.
IS WRAPPING THANK YOU CAN I HELP
WITH THAT YOU HAVE THE FIREPOWER
DO SOMETHING GOOD ABOU IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
DAPHNE DESIGN THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOU -- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE INPUT AND
INSIDE IT'S BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD
TODAY WERE IN SUPPORT BUT ALSO
WANT -- TO ENCOURAGE THE
THOUGHTFUL COMPOSITION OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WILL PROVIDE
INPUT THAT WILL INCLUDE YOUTH
WHO HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY IMPACTED
FAMILIES THEY'VE BEEN DIRECTLY
IMPACTED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES.
IT REALLY TAKES.
I DIFFERENT LANDS OF TAKING THIS
OUT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
TAKING THIS ABOUT HEALTH.
AND ABOUT SUPPORTING OUR YOUTH
IN OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AMONG THE COST DOWN -- THEY COME
FROM ME BY A LOCAL FACILITATOR
FOR HOLDEN ALL DAY -- DOWN IN
SALINAS CALIFORNIA -- THE I DO
AGREE AND GETTING THE KIDS OUT
OF THESE PROGRAMS -- HE'S
PROGRAMS WITHOUT WORK I AM LIKE
I SAID I'M FORMA INCARCERATED I
JUST.
STARTED WORKING ON MYSELF JUST
ADDED THEIR AND NOTHING IN THEIR
WORKS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRIANNA IS WIFE ARE ON ME FELLOW
AN ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
AND ALSO A GRADUATE OF THE
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEMS AND I AM HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I TOTALLY SUPPORT.
THE MOVE FROM DJJ.
TO MORE -- HEALTH BASED APPROACH
AND ALSO THAT JUST MOVING DJJ IS
NOT ENOUGH -- I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADOPT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OUTLINED IN THE MEMO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M NORMA WITH THE OTHER
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND I'M JUST HERE IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO TO STATE THAT THIS MOVE IS
NOT GOING FAR ENOUGH ESPECIALLY
OUR CHILDREN SHOULD NOT BE CAGED
UP THAT IS NOT.
A REHABILITATIVE PROCESS AND
FOLKS OF MENTAL ILLNESS DO NOT
SHOULD NEVER BE IN PRESIDENT --
SO DO TAKE THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION WE DO SUPPORT IT
BUT WE DO NEED TO GO FURTHER
THANK YOU.
DEREK MORGAN SPEAKING AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN OF OAKLAND BUT
ALSO FOR THE BECAUSE CENTER.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO URGE YOU TO
NOT FORGET -- THAT.
WE ARE HERE FOR A REASON AT C.
W. A. N. D. TODAY SHOULD BE
DISQUALIFIED FROM REHABILITATION
BECAUSE OF THEIR PAST PROMISE
THAT THEY'VE CAUSED AND THEIR
BACKSLIDING INTO THAT CLIMATE OF
ABUSE.
I URGE YOU TO ALSO LOOK AT
CURRENT FUNDING -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S OVERSIGHT FOR THE
CURRENT PROCESSES AND GRANT
GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR COMING -- AND ONE ENCOURAGE
THOSE WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THIS
OP PROCESS WILL BE LOOKING AT
THE PROPOSAL THAT IS COME
FORWARD THAT WE SEE -- WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED AS WANTED OUT IN
COSMETIC CHANGES BUT REAL STRONG
SYSTEMIC CHANGE THAT WOULD UP
PRODUCE FOR US -- OF THE
DIFFERENT RESULTS SO WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT AS WELL AS KIND
OF SYSTEM THAT SHOULD BE MUCH
MORE SUPPORTIVE OF YOUNG PEOPLE
THEN CURRENTLY THE SYSTEM THAT
WE DO HAVE -- IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR THOSE WHO ARE ENVISIONING
AND THINKING OF THIS THAT WOULD
NOT LOCK OURSELVES INTO BEING
COMMITTED TO THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW I HEAR THIS OFTEN WHERE
ANY TIME A GOOD WAY TO MAKE
CHANGE EVERYBODY THINKS
EVERYBODY WHO'S EMPLOYED.
IN A SYSTEM HAS TO ALSO MOVE
WITH THE NEW SYSTEM AND THAT.
IN THE EFFORT TO TRY TO DO THAT
YOU LIMIT YOUR VISION.
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN PEOPLE WHO
WORKED IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
WILL BE EMPLOYED IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM BUT IF IT IF I TASK IS TO
TAKE ALL THE FOLKS WHO WORK.
IN A CERTAIN SYSTEM AND PUT THEM
BACK INTO THE NEW SYSTEM WE WILL
END UP WITH THE SAME SYSTEM AND
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE REAL
CHALLENGE.
IS HOW DO WE ENVISION SOMETHING
WITHOUT NECESSARILY HAVING A
FACTORY IN THAT ELEMENT KNOWING
THAT THOSE THINGS WILL WILL WORK
THEIR WAY OUT AND WILL
EVENTUALLY COME TO BE BUT IF
THEY BECOME THE FOUNDATION. FOR
THE STRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW IF IF EVERYONE WHO'S
EMPLOYED CURRENTLY WITH DJJ IS
THE FOUNDATION OF THE STRUCTURE
YOU'RE GONNA LIMIT WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE.
BECAUSE THAT'S A DIFFICULT THING
TO DO.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
BUILD SOMETHING THAT'S ROUND AND
YOU'VE GOT A SQUARE PEG IT MAY
NOT FIT IN.
YOU KNOW IT JUST MAY NOT AND SO
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
GOALS ARE CLEAR.
OF WHAT WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH.
HAVE THE CREATIVITY IN THE
VISION AND THE RESOURCES TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
YOU TALK ABOUT PERSONNEL.
BUT OFTENTIMES IN THIS PLACE WE
TALK ABOUT PERSONAL FIRST.
AND THEN WE TALK ABOUT OTHER
STUFF AND TRY TO MAKE IT WORK
AND IT NEVER SEEMS TO WORK I RUN
INTO THIS ALL THE TIME WITH
SCHOOLS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE GOTTA WORK BUT
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY'S THERE AND
THEN AS A RESULT THE KIDS DON'T
GET WHAT THEY NEED.
SO WE WANT TO BASICALLY RELEASE
OURSELVES FROM THAT ****.
AND REALIZE THAT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS CREATING A VISION
OF WHAT KIND OF SYSTEM SHOULD
EXIST.
AND IT AS A RESULT OF THAT HOW
WHAT IS A PERSONAL NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT AND DRIVE THAT SYSTEM
AND I HOPE THAT'S THE VISION
THAT WOULD GO AWAY.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S THERE.
THIS WILL COME BACK THIS IS NOT
BEEN FUNDED YET IS BEING HELD
OVER THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OUR
FINAL ITEM I BELIEVE IS FINAL IS
THAT RIGHT IT IS ARE THESE
OFFICES TRADING POST IS HERE --
YES SOME PEOPLE FAMOUS OKAY.
THE TONER.
OKAY GOOD WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
OUR FOLKS WHO POST WE'VE ASKED
FOR A FIVE MINUTE PRESENTATION.
ON THE CLOSEST RECOMMENDATION --
FOR INCREASE OFFICER TRAINING
UHHUH [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT
THIS BUDGET HEARING.
MY NAME IS MANNY ALVAREZ AND
I'VE SERVICE HE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE.
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING --
FOR IS WE ARE COMMONLY KNOWN
POST.
SEATED TO MY LEFT IS MISS MARIA
SAND OF ALL.
THE POST ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR FIELD SERVICES.
FIRST OFF MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN FOR THE
ONE TIME FUNDING.
OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO
PRIORITIZE DE ESCALATION MENTAL
HEALTH TRAINING.
THE FUNDING IS CONSIDERED THREE
YEAR FUNDING TO BE EXPENDED BY
JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALTHOUGH WE
MENTIONED IN OUR IN OUR REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN MARCH.
THE WE HAD SPENT LESS THAN FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF THAT MONEY
WE EXPECT TO HAVE A FUNDING
EXPENDED BY JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BECAUSE
CURRENTLY HAS TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT COURSES WHICH
INCLUDE TRAINING CONCEPTS ON DE
ESCALATION USE OF FORCE.
OR MENTAL HEALTH.
DO A HISTORICALLY PAPER BASED
PROCESS FOR AGENCY TRAINING
REIMBURSEMENT REQUESTS WE ARE
NOW JUST STARTING TO PROCESS.
THOSE -- REQUESTS FROM.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE
ANTICIPATE BY THIS FRIDAY WE
WILL HAVE ISOLATED ALL TRAINING
REIMBURSEMENT REQUESTS FOR THE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
COURSES AND SHORTLY THEREAFTER
GET THEM PAID EXPEDITIOUSLY.
WE HAVE NOT YET UTILIZED ANY OF
THE FUNDING -- TO PURCHASE DE
ESCALATION US OF FORCE.
A QUICK MINUTE.
WE HAVE HOWEVER REVIEW
TECHNOLOGY -- FROM FIVE SEPARATE
COMPANIES WHO PRODUCE FORCE
OPTION SIMULATORS AND OR VIRTUAL
REALITY SYSTEMS.
ADDITIONALLY ON MAY TWENTY
SECOND AND TWENTY THIRD.
WE WILL BE REVIEWING EXTENDED
FORMAT DE ESCALATION USE OF
FORCE TRAINING SCENARIOS
DEVELOPED BY THE OREGON
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
IN THE WASHINGTON STATE
UNIVERSITY.
FRANKLY WE'RE JUST NOT
COMFORTABLE FROM A TECHNOLOGY
STANDPOINT TO ISSUE AN RFP FOR
NEW EQUIPMENT AT LEAST NOT YET.
ADDITIONALLY ON APRIL SECOND WE
AWARDED THREE POINT TWO MILLION
IT IN INNOVATION GRANTS FOR
AWARDING GRANTS WAS A FIRST FOR
POST.
IT TOOK US A FEW MONTHS TO
DEVELOP THE A ROBUST PROGRAM --
THAT WE NOW HAVE.
WE ANTICIPATE ROLLING OUT A
SECOND.
R. F. P. IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN TO FULLY EXPAND THE
REMAINING ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION.
ON INNOVATION GRANTS.
RAMPING UP THE PROCESS IN
PRIORITY PROJECTS AND I
MENTIONED -- PREVIOUSLY TAKES
TIME.
WE ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
WITH THE OVERALL TIMING OF THE
EXPENDITURES.
IN REGARDS TO NEXT YEAR'S.
BUDGET GOVERNOR NEEDS SOME SIR
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR POST
INCLUDES A THIRTY FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION.
CONSISTING OF FOURTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION FOR RESTORATION
CREATION OF NEW TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR USE OF FORCE.
DE ESCALATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
TRAINING.
THE POST BCP ADDRESSES THE
FUNDING AND THREE CUSTOMARY
MANNERS ADMINISTRATION.
OF FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION.
MEETING DELIVERY FIVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION.
LOCAL ASSISTANCE AN AGENCY
REIMBURSEMENT OF TWENTY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION.
UNFORTUNATELY DISPLAYING THE
FUNDING IN THE B. C. P.
UTILIZING THESE CATEGORIES DOES
NOT CLEARLY DELINEATE HOW CLOSE
WE UTILIZE THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR USE OF
FORCE.
DE ESCALATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
TRAINING.
I IF YOU WOULD LIKE I CAN GO
INTO SPECIFICS ON HOW WE AND
EXPECT TO USE THAT MONEY OR I
CAN.
ANSWER QUESTIONS WHATEVER YOU'D
LIKE MADAM CHAIR I KNOW YOU KNOW.
A LOT OF THIS BUT I'M.
RIGHT CAN YOU TO I'M PREPARED TO
CONTINUE IF YOU LIKE WELL
THEY'RE NOT HERE SO -- AND I'VE
I'VE HEARD OF ABOUT IT BEFORE MY
STAFF S. SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
FINE WITH THE THAT WILL THAT THE
THE OF THIS RESPOND.
TO OF FINANCE HAVING A RESPONSE.
HELLO.
I NEED ONLY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO HAVE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR YOU ON THIS
ISSUE.
THE FIRST IS THAT THIS PROPOSAL
REPRESENTS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE AND ONGOING LEVEL
FUNDING IS OVER 60%.
AND TO REALLY IT WE THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE FOR SHOULD FOCUS
ON ENSURING THAT WHATEVER
FUNDING IS PROVIDED CONSISTENT
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND
IT REFLECTS -- THEIR THOUGHTS.
THE PLAN THAT'S BEEN LAID OUT
AND AND DISCUSSED IS ONE WAY.
OF USING THE DOLLARS IT'S A
THOUGHTFUL WAY POST REALLY REAL
VALUE IN THE PROGRAMS ETCETERA.
BUT THE LEGISLATURE HAS IN PRIOR
YEARS INDICATED ALTERNATIVE WAYS
THEY WANTED TO DEDICATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES AND THAT'S
AN EQUALLY ACCEPTABLE WAY OF
USING THE DOLLARS.
SO OUR SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER
FINDINGS PROVIDED WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING ANNUAL REPORTING.
ON SPECIFIC OUTCOME IN
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT ARE
TIED TO ANY NEW FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDED.
AND SO THIS WILL REALLY HELP THE
LEGISLATURE MONITOR THAT THE
FUNDS ARE USED YOU KNOW IN THE
COURTS OF LEGISLATIVE
EXPECTATIONS. TO MEASURE THE
IMPACT OF THEM AND THIS TYPE OF
DATA WILL ALSO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE MOVING FORWARD
DETERMINE WHAT'S THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF DELIVERING
SERVICES.
AND IF ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
PROVIDED THE FUTURE WHERE IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO INVEST THOSE
DOLLARS THANK YOU.
IT'S VERY THOUGHTFUL THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE YES. THIRTY SOME JEWS.
THERE WE GO GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR SHOWN ON WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED FUNDING -- AND OUR
VIEWS -- LONG OVERDUE NAME
INVESTMENT INTO LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY ACROSS A CALIFORNIA AS A
PRIMARILY TRAINING ORGANIZATION
IF THERE'S ANY INFORMATION WE
CAN PROVIDE ABOUT WHO WE'VE.
TRAINED IN SOME OUTCOMES EITHER
THROUGH THE LA.
ELIAS'S RECOMMENDATION WE WE'D
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT -- WHEN
THIS ITEM COMES BEFORE VOTE BUT --
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED
FUNDING INCIDENT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR LUCIA
MUCH LEARNED HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION ARE
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
PROPOSE FUNDING.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO STAY ENGAGED IN
THIS DISCUSSION AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WE HOPE THAT
THAT YOU SUPPORT AT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY WANT TO THANK POST FOR
PROVIDING US WITH THIS
INFORMATION -- IT WAS
INTERESTING I WAS IN A MEETING
THIS MORNING CONCERNING --
POLICE OFFICER TRAINING AND
SOMEONE SAYS WELL YOU HAVE BEEN
GIVEN HIM ANY MONEY WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS HILARIOUS AND I SAID
TO YOU LAST YEAR GIVING TWENTY
FIVE MILLION WHICH IS 50% OF
THEIR CURRENT BUDGET -- YOU KNOW
SO THEY'VE SEEN AN INCREASE WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE AN INCREASE AND
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT WE
HAVE TO TIE THAT MONEY WHICH WE
DID INITIALLY.
TO ISSUES OF DE ESCALATION AS
WELL AS FOR PROVIDE INNOVATIVE
GRANTS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT A
LOT OF EXCITING THINGS HAPPENING
IN IN THE VARIOUS JURISDICTIONS.
AND A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY HELP
SOME GO ALONG WAY WITH USE OF
DRONES AND ALL KINDS OF THINGS
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CREATE A
SAFER COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL THOSE THAT ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY SO -- I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THIS I THINK THAT THE AS
WE TALK ABOUT -- THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO WE WE'RE OFTEN TALKING
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
ISSUE IS THAT MOST OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THE
DEAL AROUND THE ISSUE OF
TRAINING.
MAKING SURE THAT THE WE HAVE GOT
HIGH GOALS EXPECTATIONS WHAT WE
WANT TO ACCOMPLISH LAID OUT
THERE BUT IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH
THOSE THINGS WE NEED TO ALSO
HAVE TRAINING ATTACHED TO IT.
SO I KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME HITS
IN THE PAST WITH POST IN TERMS
OF NOT GETTING MUCH MORE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES -- WE WE
LOOK TO BASICALLY BE ABLETO
SUPPORT -- TRAINING AND THE
ACTIVITIES THAT AT THAT SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATURE'S VISION OF WHAT
TRAINING SHOULD LOOK LIKE SO I
REALLY THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR
ALWAYS GIVING ME VERY GOOD
INFORMATION CONCERNING WHAT
YOU'RE DOING -- AND I'M EXCITED
ABOUT IT I'D LIKE TO AT SOME
POINT TO THE JUST THE TITLE THE
LIST OF OF THE GRANT IS WHAT
THEY DO WHAT THEY DO BECAUSE I'M
KIND OF INTERESTED IN PEOPLE'S
INNOVATION.
AND I THINK IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
ASK FOLKS AT AT ONE LEVEL WHAT
ARE THEY DOING THAT COULD BE
HELPFUL AND HOW CAN WE HELP THEM
DO BETTER BUT MORE POINTED TO
SHARE THAT WITH OTHERS.
YOU KNOW TOO OFTEN WE DO A LOT
OF INNOVATION IN SILOS.
AND SO PEOPLE DON'T GET A CHANCE
TO REALLY SEE WHAT OTHER DID
OTHER JURISDICTIONS ARE DOING
BUT THEY DO WHAT THEY DO
EXTREMELY WELL AND SO HOPEFULLY
WITH AT SOME POINT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO SHARE THAT.
ACROSS THE VARIOUS JURISDICTION
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OUR WHAT OUR
OFFICERS AND DIFFERENT GROUPS
ARE DOING AND HOW WAS THE
BOARDING THEM AND ACCOMPLISHING
THAT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
IT SOME POINT DOES NOT WE URGE
IF I CAN SEE A LIST OF WHAT
WHAT'S.
GOING ON WITH THE GRANTS I'D BE
HAPPY TO LOOK AT IT AND AND SEE
WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IN TERMS
OF INNOVATION HERE AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND SEE IF THERE'S A WAY
OF EXPANDING THAT AND AND AND
GREATER WHERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR CONTACT MANAGER -- WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK AND IS SHE
ISN'T HERE TO IT JUST AS I WAS
NO IT'S I AM HEY I'M I'M NEXT
DOOR VOTING SUPPOSEDLY -- AND I
GUESS I WILL GET THERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING THANK YOU --
BUT BACK TO THE OF OF THE
FIFTEEN ITEMS THAT WE VOTED ON
EARLY ALL OF THOSE ITEMS GOT ON
A OUT ON A THREE ZERO BOTH THEIR
VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WHICH ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES FOR RESPONSE ACTIVITY
[inaudible]
UNLESS I HEY THAT'S NOT OUT ON A
FOUR ZERO VOTERS MISTER IS DOING
ALL THE I GUESS HE'S NOT COMING
BACK WHO JONES SAWYER.
THE STAFF JUST CALLED PEOPLE TRY
TO COME BACK SO OKAY SO DO WE
KNOW WHEN HE'LL TRY.
ALL CALL YEAH CALL AND SEE AND
AND WE WILL CLOSE OUT YET.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS A
LOS ALAMEDA -- STARBASE
CLASSROOM RIGHT NOW IS.
THREE ZERO HI OKAY RIGHT NOW IT
FOUR ZERO WILL HOLD IT OPEN
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE LOS
ALAMEDA LOS NATIONAL GUARD
READINESS CENTER.
HI IT'S NOT THAT FOUR ZERO OR
WHICH IS THE STATE ACTIVITY DUTY
COMPENSATION JUST WHAT WE'RE AT
THREE ZERO HI.
IF THAT'S FOUR ZERO WELL HOLD IT
OPEN WORK FOR WARRIORS ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WITH THREE ZERO ONE
HI.
OKAY THAT MAKES THIS FOUR ZERO
WILL HOLD IT OPEN ISSUE NUMBER --
SIX WE'RE AT THREE ZERO I THAT
MAKES THIS FOUR ZERO WILL HOLD
IT OPEN -- ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS THE FEDERAL TRUST
AUTHORITY INCREASE WITH.
THREE ZERO I NAY MAKES IS THAT
FOUR ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THE WILL HOLD IT OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
ADJUSTMENT TO PARTNERSHIP WITH
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS AND OTHER
TECHNICAL JUSTICE WITH THREE
ZERO ONE DAY HI OKAY THAT TAKES
IS THE FOUR ZERO ISSUE NUMBER
NINE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY
ACT ASSESS ABILITY IMPROVEMENT
AT TWO INSTITUTIONS. ONE DAY I
LET'S SAID THERE WERE NOT FOUR
ZERO IT WILL HOLD IT OPEN ISSUE
NUMBER TEN WHICH IS AT THREE
ZERO STATEWIDE TELEHEALTH
SERVICES.
HI THAT BRINGS US TO FOUR ZERO
WILL HOLD IT OPEN ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM STAFFING.
HI WE'RE AT FOUR ZERO OF WILL
HOLD IT OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE WHICH IS THE
TRUE LISTA PAROLE OFFICE
RELOCATION.
I WOULD NOT FOUR ZERO OKAY HOLD
IT OPEN ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
WHICH IS -- LA PAROLE OFFICE
RELOCATION WITH.
THREE ZERO HI OKAY WOULD NOT
FOUR ZERO HOLD IT OPEN ISSUE
NUMBER FOURTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES STATEWIDE
SURCHARGE FOR THE FEE INCREASE
WITH.
THREE ZERO HI OKAY THAT TAKES IS
THE FOUR ZERO WILL HOLD IT OPEN
AND RENT INCREASES OUR FINAL
ISSUE WITH. THREE ZERO ONE I
WOULD NOTE FOUR ZERO AND WILL
HOLD IT OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible] FOUR
ZERO YOU'RE VOTING.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS I MINISTRY
RELOCATION RESOURCES ISSUE
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS LOS ALAMEDA
STARBASE CLASSROOM WITH.
FOUR ZERO THAT'S A FIVE ZERO
CLOSE THAT OUT ISSUE NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS A LOS ALAMEDA WAS
NATIONAL GUARD READY MISS CENTER
WITH.
FOUR ZERO I WOULD NOT FIVE ZERO
CLOSE IT OUT ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS THE STATE ACTIVE DUTY
COMPENSATION ADJUSTMENT WEIRD
FOUR ZERO HI.
WE'RE NOW FIVE ZERO CLOSE IT OUT --
WORKED FOR WARRIORS ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE WITH FOUR ZERO HI WE'RE NOT
FIVE ZERO CLOSE THAT OUT --
ISSUE NUMBER SIX SACRAMENTO'S
FIRE APPARATUS MAINTENANCE SHOP.
WITH FOUR ZERO BY WHEN OUT FIVE
ZERO CLOSE IT OUT OF FEDERAL
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS
FEDERAL TRUST TO FUND A FORTY
INCREASE.
WERE IT.
FOUR ZERO FIVE AT THIS MAKES A
FIVE ZERO IN CLOSE AT ITEM OUT --
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
ADJUSTMENT TO PARTNERSHIP WOULD
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS -- YES IT
WOULD FOUR ZERO THAT'S FIVE FIVE
ZERO SO CLOSE THAT ITEM OUT
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENT.
AT TWO INSTITUTION ISSUE NUMBER
NINE WITH.
FOUR ZERO DOES THAT AL WOULD NOT
FIVE ZERO STATEWIDE TELECAST
HEALTH SERVICES WOULD FOUR ZERO
ISSUE NUMBER -- TEN I OKAY THIS
ZERO CLOSE THAT ITEM OUT
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
WHICH FOUR ZERO HI OKAY THAT
MAKES IT FIVE ZERO EAST THAT'S
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN THE CLOTHES
THAT ONE ALPHA TO LIST A PAROLE
OFFICE RELOCATION.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE WITH WITH ZERO NOW THAT'S
FIVE ZERO CLOSE THAT ITEMS OUT
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH IS A
LOS ANGELES PAROLE OFFICE
RELOCATION.
HI THAT -- CLOTHES THAT ITEM OUT
SO THAT MAKES IT -- FIVE ZERO I
AM FOURTEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES STATEWIDE
SURCHARGE FEE INCREASE.
IT WOULD FOUR ZERO I WOULD NOT
FIVE ZERO THAT ADAM WAS CLOSED
OUT AND THE LAST ITEM FIFTEEN
RENT INCREASES WITH.
FOUR ZERO FIVE THAT MAKES IT
FIVE ZERO THE ISSUE FIFTEEN IN
THAT CLOSE THAT OUT WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED